This is Jocko podcast number
47 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
And I went a little long
with a couple of reviews.
We've done some interviews.
We interviewed JP Denelle,
and I've got a ton of really
solid books that I'm reading.
I'm learning a lot from all of them and
just getting a lot out of those books
that I'm reading right now about war and
about leadership and about human nature
and about life,
but kind of failed to answer
questions for the last few podcasts.
Questions from the interwebs,
from everybody out there that's listening
and the question had been piling up.
So tonight we're going to simply dive
into some questions from you all out
there. So let's get right
to it. Echo Charles. Yes.
Question number one,
what do he got Jocko,
do you think that most MMA fighters
have what it takes to be seals,
the mental and physical,
the brutal weight cut the brutal fight
camp and stepping into a cage with a
train and a elite opponent?
Well,
this is one of those questions where
you might think there's like a really
definitive answer,
but there isn't really,
some MMA fighters could definitely
be great seals for sure.
Some of them actually wouldn't
stand a chance as deals.
And there's a lot of things that make
people quit and not want to be seals or
quit during seal training.
You know you've got the Walker.
Some people don't like to water, some
people are uncomfortable in the water,
great athletes,
not good in the water.
Some people don't like the
cold and they can understand,
they can take all kinds of
punishment of physical nature,
but they don't like the cold.
Some people don't like heights and you
get to the top of a 40 or 50 foot cargo
net and you've got to climb over
that little pole at the top,
get to the other side.
Some people don't like that.
Some people can't do some
simple stuff like memorize.
You can't memorize certain facts.
And there's a,
there is a intellectual
level that you have to have.
Some people aren't situationally
aware, right? So some of
these, like for instance,
you know,
you don't use certain MMA fighters who
are real wild and it's one of their good
characteristics is that they're,
they're kind of out of control.
It helps them do wild things and a fight,
unexpected things.
You can't be like that in the kill house.
We'd go in live fire,
right? You can't have that.
Why you need to be able to suppress
it and some people can't suppress it.
So what you'd end up with someone is
someone that's gonna have safety issues
because they there to instinctual and
they can't get those instincts under
control.
Some people might have too much endurance,
but not enough strength to,
some people might have too much
strength and not enough endurance.
Some people are injury prone,
right?
Some people are just injury prone
and it's not their fault. Many cases,
but they are and,
and then you take,
so that's sort of the things that it
takes to be in the seal teams that would,
could hold up or trip up somebody
that's just standard MMA fighter.
Now the same thing is true with seals.
That would be MMA fighters, right? Or, or
could seal potentially be an MMA fighter.
And there's been,
there's been a few sales out of that if
you don't better fought really well and
good fighters and all that.
But to make a blanket statement,
there's going to be things that
trip people up. And for instance,
some guys in the seal teams there,
they're not the best athlete. Their,
their athletic ability is not as high
as it might need to be to be a true
competitor in MMA. You
know, whether that's,
they don't have the explosiveness or
they don't have the coordination of the
flexibility, there's some thing that's
going to make them not competitive.
And normally those guys, I mean sometimes
they might not be the best seals,
you know,
but some of those guys are super smart
and so the reason that they're good seals
because they're just, they're
just tactically sound in
order. Really good leaders,
they're never going to beat people on
the range shooting cause they're just not
that coordinated.
I don't have the hand eye coordination,
but they're good seals anyways.
But when you put them in a purely
physical competition like MMA,
I shouldn't say, well most a more
physical on physical competition like MMA,
they're not going to do
well. And of course obviously
there's a skillset, right?
MMA fighters train MMA all the time.
That's what they do.
They train Jujitsu and boxing and
wrestling and more tie in judo.
That's what they do. And seals also
train all the time. But guess what?
When you're in seal team,
you're not just training,
just fighting, right? You're training,
shooting and you're training
tactics and your training,
patrolling and land navigation
of parachuting in combat
diving and fast roping,
rappelling and waterborne operations,
all this stuff.
And then on top of all that stuff,
which is the stuff that you
actually really need to train,
then they put on a level of mixed martial
arts training to make sure that if you
are,
for whatever reason,
without a weapon or if you need to handle
somebody that doesn't have a weapon,
and so therefore you might not be in the
right to just shoot him and kill him.
You got to have you all
been handling yourself.
So there's some level of MMA training,
some fundamental Jiu Jitsu skills,
some fundamental striking skills,
some fundamental wrestling
skills that that seals get.
But it's not at the level of what a
real MMA fighter is going to have.
So
with all that,
I think there is a,
a good percentage of MMA fighters that
would make it through seal training and
be good seals and there's a good number
of seals that would probably make really
good solid MMA fighters if they chose
to do that and focus their lives on it.
Cause there are some common
traits with both of them.
Both of them take hard work.
Both of them take some level
of physical suffering. Right.
Grind it both.
I mean you,
you've been around when we're running
an MMA camps for people, it's a grind.
It's a grind. It's a day in,
day out grind. Now there's
some luxury to that grind.
There's some luxury that grind because
when you're in an MMA camp, yeah,
you work hard as hell from,
you know,
seven in the morning until nine o'clock
doing your strength and conditioning.
But then you're going to go home and
you're going to get a massage and you're
gonna get,
you're gonna have some really good food
standing by and you're going to sit down,
you're going to relax,
and then at 11 o'clock you can go back
to the gym and now you're going to do,
you're,
you're grappling training and you're
going to train really hard for an hour,
maybe an hour and a half.
You can do drills. You'd get
worn out again, and then,
then you're going to go eat some lunch.
You're going to relax,
you're going to go back home.
You're going to lay down,
maybe take a little ice bath,
then his little Jacuzzi.
So there's some luxury to the MMA
did in the seal teams. There's not,
it's not happening.
You're just getting ground
down when you're going
through the basic training and
when you're going through, you know,
the advanced workup training, you're,
you're just getting beat down
all the time. It's a grind,
but both of them are a grind.
And that's why I think though the work
ethic that comes with a really good seal
or a really good MMA fighter,
there's a very strong similarity there.
And the ability to take that grind is,
is what I think that that
intrinsic discipline is what
would make the crossover
occur.
So that would make a seal into a good
MMA fighter or an MMA fighter into a good
seal or a good special operations guy.
Yeah. And and there's the crossover.
It's ultimately just like you said, it's
kind of hard to, I identify it overall,
the thrilled general cause like
an MMA fighter is training. Sure.
He's training to be a better
MMA fighter in general,
but mainly it's training for an event.
So knows okay it's going
to be this many rounds,
it's going to be this long per round.
I'm going to get this much rest for this
route and I'm training to win that. Yup.
Real specific.
So the training is,
if it's good training,
it's going to best train him to
function in that event and give them the
parameters. Yeah. Combat Navy seal, not
like that parameter you straight up.
Can you, a great example of this is
Tim Kennedy, right? Tim Kennedy's, uh,
Greenbrae special forces guy and
he's a complete beast, you know,
and he's a great example of a guy that
has the commitment, the discipline,
the dedication to be a,
a special forces guy.
And that translates right into how
he works out and trains for fights.
That guy trains like a madman for fights.
And I think that's a great example of
somebody not only can do one or the other,
he does both, you know, know real time
he's in it. He's fighting November 15th.
Right.
That gets Rashad Evans so good on him.
And I actually had like another
follow on question to this,
which is in the same
arena, who would win? Yeah.
Who would win,
who would win in a fight between a
UFC fighter and a seal team member.
And I'll just go ahead and broaden
that out to make it like, you know,
a special operations guy because people
put special operations personnel onto a
pedestal of you know,
totally being able to kick everyone's ass,
which is,
well to answer the question
in its simplest form,
if the,
if there was a fight and it's
mixed martial arts competition,
so like in a cage what you
were just talking about with
a referee and that's the
way it's going to be and there's
five minute rounds and there's five,
five minute rounds,
where is he was going to win this fight
barring a massive weight difference
and and a rare special operations guy
that has a high level of training.
If you take a 175 pound special operations
guy that just trained like a normal
special operations guy has,
doesn't have any specialties,
we're not talking Tim Kennedy,
we're not talking to any of these guys
that actually are committed and getting
into it and train outside the
actual discipline in their job.
If it's just a normal run of the mill
guy from the special operations community
against a professional UFC fighter
in the same weight class, it's
the UFC fighters going to win.
That's, those are the facts. And um,
again, that's an occasion. And I
know this because you know what,
I've trained with a lot of really high
level UFC fighters and I mean I've
trained with,
with Randy and Tito and I've trained with
Brandon Vera and with Quentin Rampage
Jackson and I've chain with Dan Henderson
and Matt Front of train with Bisbing
too soft trained with a lot of these guys.
You don't,
none of them at a like all the time,
although brand of air.
And I used to try to get there all
the time, but, and he's awesome. Um,
but I trained with those guys, you know,
I trained with those guys and you know,
not to mention Dean Dean lister,
I've been trained with forever.
So I've trained and when
I trained with those guys,
a majority of the time I would train
grappling specific so we wouldn't be just
doing straight MMA. So
we're training in, in a,
in an arena that's geared towards me,
you know,
some somewhere that I'm actually good at,
right.
Have been trained you just for 20 years.
And so
when I go in the cage with those guys,
or when I've trained with those guys,
I'm competitive with them,
you know, so, you know, we,
we have good training, right?
We're, we're, it's not like,
yeah, we have good training.
It's good competitive
training with all those guys.
But I've been training
this stuff for a long time.
So my magical special operations powers,
they,
I know what they are and they're
not real. Um, you're going to,
you have to learn how to fight to
be able to hang with these guys.
And if you don't know how to train,
if I put, you know, because I,
when I trained with a regular, you know,
got a seal that doesn't train, of course,
you, it's Jujitsu. You fricking
destroyed them. They have no chance.
So when, if you take a guy that's
just a normal guy that doesn't train,
they're going to get their
ass beat just like any other,
you'd get no magical powers. Will
you be tough? Sure. We'll you know,
and this is good. Like, you know,
you take your average seal and
you start teaching her Jujitsu,
they're great training partners
because they're strong,
they have great endurance, they go
freaking hard, yet they don't quit.
They don't give up. They'll keep training
with you until they don't tap easy.
So yeah, they're great training partners
that end. The more you teach them,
the better they're going to get and
they're going to learn quickly because
they're going to be focused on it.
So that's all good.
But the fact of the matter is you
take a skilled and, and I, you know,
can you take a skilled UFC fighter and
it doesn't matter that you were a quote
unquote, you know, navy seal or
special operations guy. That's,
that's just not going to happen.
So
now the,
the other kind of thing on this is if
you take both people now out of the cage
and you put them into a
survival type situation,
now the special operations person's going
to have a much better chance because
first of all,
they're gonna be able to,
they're going to try and avoid
the bad situation if they can.
And if they do have to fight,
they are much more likely to use some
kind of a improvised weapon to do some
kind of sneak attack,
to have backup right in the form of other
guys that you didn't realize were with
him. And all of a sudden you're
getting hit in the head with a bottle.
It's the professional fighter. Of
course, it has a huge advantage,
but there will be,
there is some,
when you get out of the cage
and there's no referee, there's,
there's some things that,
you know,
your average special operations guys
are going to be thinking about that your
normal person wouldn't be thinking
about in these situations. Um,
so, you know, that's why I said, you
know, just in general, first of all,
don't get any street fights. It's not
smart. It doesn't get you anywhere.
And you see guys that are in the military,
just in general,
they kind of have
another little level that they might
take things too, right? And that's,
that's, you know, you think you're
getting a little fist fight, right?
And you think all of them,
I'm in a borrow,
was getting a little fist fight with
this person. The next thing you know,
someone's biting off your nose,
right?
Or someone's ripping off
your ear or someone sticking
a fork in your eye because
that's the kind of thing,
like that's the kind of thing that you
take one of these people who's trained in
that has a little switch in their
head that they go, oh, I'm going to,
I'm going to combat scenario right now
where this guy's attacking me and I'm
going to chew off. I'm going to chew off
his nose. I'm gonna read off as a year,
or how many gouged out his eyes? I'm
gonna do it right now as fast as I can.
So that's why,
you know,
just you got to use Costa
and I got actually one of my,
one of my buddies back in the day
there was,
we were in a bar and some guy who was
getting cocky and said something to a girl
and you know,
he knew the girl and Blah Blah Blah.
And there was whatever situation.
So my buddy's like, hey, hey,
can you go ahead and apologize that
girl, you know, cause that wasn't cool.
He said it all nice. Like, yeah,
like just all months and the guys,
you know what? And he
says, Hey, no, no problem.
I just, you said something to the
girl over there. You see her? Yeah,
we do with the red shirt on.
Yeah.
You said something to her and it was kind
of offensive. So if you could just go,
you know, apologize to her then, you
know, we're all good here and, and it,
what do you mean we're all good?
No,
I mean if you can just apologize to
her then we're all good. And you know,
the guy says something like, you
know, what are you going to do about?
And as he's finishing those words,
the guy was smoking a cigarette.
As he's finishing those words,
my buddy in a millisecond,
in a nanosecond,
like faster than you
can snap your fingers.
He snatches the cigarette out of the
guy's mouth and shoves it with absolute
laser target,
precision up,
the guys know a burning cigarette.
So this dude just, and he put
it, you put it in there deep.
I don't even know how he did it. Like
a Ninja move. Well Baum, it's up there.
The dude collapses. I mean, can
you imagine? You know, I mean,
you've seen people like put a cigarette
out on their arm or whatever and it
leaves a scar for the rest of their life.
He shoved the cigarette,
the burning cigarettes up,
the guys knows the guy collapses to the
ground and just like screaming in it.
I mean, completely defenseless.
So that's the kind of thing.
Maybe that guy was a tough guy. Maybe
that guy was thinking, oh, I'm a boxer,
or whatever.
This guy might've been,
I don't even know because the fight was
over before it even started because the
guy had a burning cigarette jammed up
in his nasal cavity in a split second
fights over. So that's the kind of thing
that let's be friends with each other.
Let's just try and treat each
other with respect out there.
So we're not getting into fights because
I've got a bunch of stories like that
and they don't end well,
you know,
if they don't end well and yeah,
that's kind of like,
um,
like special operations guys.
That's kind of an eye, I'm not
that guy that you're talking about.
He's not special operations guy.
Right?
That was just the guy that did the
cigarette up the nose. Oh no, he's a seal.
Oh yeah, he, when this was, this
was years ago, many, many years ago.
And yeah, he did it just like that. And
that's the kind of thing, like, again,
the guy that he's talking to thinks he's
a tough guy, thinks, oh, I'm a tough guy.
Who, what's this? What's this
little guy talking to me?
Talking smack telling me you apologize.
I don't have to apologize anybody.
And this was also pre MMA days, but
you know, maybe the guy's a boxer,
maybe the guy's a wrestler, he
may, it might be a tough guy,
but I guess apparently when you
get a burning shoved up your nose,
you're not tough anymore.
Just goes over like that.
Yeah. Even, I mean, even better then
as an example, he is where first off,
if the guy, you know how the, how you
said he's saying it all calm like, hey,
just go ahead and apologize what? It
made me nervous, right? They're like, oh,
this guy's cute. Anyway, but
that's a side thing. So like, yeah,
so a special operations guy compared
to an MMA guy, he's, he's about every,
he's thinking beyond the fight. He's
thinking straight up, this is a battle.
So how can I win this fucking war?
You know,
MMA fighter is thinking
like when we fight,
how am I going to beat you up with all
my skills? And he will typically will,
unless you have equal or better skills,
you're going to get beat up in a fight.
Yeah. So, but the tack that he liked,
the other guy, he's thinking tactical,
he's thinking, okay, you
know, he'll probably,
and according to the guys that I hang
around with, when they walk in a room,
just like a Jujitsu guy, when you, when
you, when a person is presented to you,
you're thinking you did two
already, you're thinking, okay,
from here a solid takedown
would come a special operators,
I could stick my pen in this guy's eyes
and there's the door and you know that,
you know, let's say, let's say other guys
just came in. Okay. So I got five guys,
he has like eight before any fight, no
fight, no nothing. This is just the way,
you know, the way that kind of the
mind works. And then, so yeah, if,
and he's planning like the your guy,
he had that planner Eddie, you know,
it's not like he was like,
oh, I'm just gonna attack in.
That just Kinda came about during the
process of the tech. He knew like, okay,
he had a cigarette. That's part of my
plan, my tactic, you know. Um, so yeah,
when you go outside of
just the site, no, no
too. Like you think about you, you
know, the Applegate, rex Applegate,
the whole idea of,
of self defense being gross motor
movements instead of fine motor movements.
So if you ever look at
some of the old school, um,
unarmed combat from the military,
it's all based on this idea
that when you get in a fight,
you want to do these big gross
motor skills. In other words,
just giant movements with
your fist and with your legs.
So there's no really fine motor skills
because when your adrenaline's pumping
and you're in this fight,
you're going to make little mistakes.
Imagine the fine motor skills it takes
to grab a cigarette and it up someone's
nose in a split second node. Uh, you know,
there's another story and I don't
know why Tim, Tim Kennedy and I,
we talked about it before we came on the
podcast and we did, we didn't get to it.
Maybe we'll talk about it next time cause
we reviewed the whole story and it's a
great story.
As you know,
he trained at the pit in San Louis
Obispo for awhile and seals used to do
training up there and one night and all
the guys that trained with Tim at the
time, um, they all used to work as
bouncers. And these guys are pro,
I'm going to say, I wish I could
remember the names of the crew,
but it's basically the old school
St Louis Obispo pit crew, right?
So it's, I want to say Gan Mcgee, Tim
Kennedy, Chuck Liddell, that crew,
right? Those guys before,
you know, the UFC was big.
Those guys all work as
bouncers in San Louis Obispo.
So some were doing some training up
in the area. It went out in town.
I've got into a fight and they,
the, the guys got their ask.
The seals got their ass kicked pretty
much by, and, and it was, you know,
Tim and I were laughing
about it because again,
this is before the UFC was really
popular and they got into a fight.
And of course,
not only is it a bunch of UFC or at least
high level MMA guys that are working
as bouncers. So they're sober fighting
against a bunch of drunk team guys.
And it was funny cause I,
they said, man, you know,
cause he seals got their asses kicked
in there, kind of like came back like,
Oh man, oh no, no, these belters were
tough. And then I go, well what was it?
And they're like Saint Louis Obispo.
And then somehow through the grapevine,
through the MMA grapevine there,
somebody told me back, Hey Jocko,
those guys that got, it was these guys,
it was guys from the pit. And I was like,
oh, okay. I know that story
by the way, cause a guy, he
was a new guy, he was like,
yeah, I'm not gonna say anything.
I think he's still in his name,
but he met him through the cake nuts,
you know, they'd come by and all that.
That's how I met JP. Kind
of the same way. But, um,
but he would always come in
the club that I worked at.
And so we kind of became friends,
you know. So after we're done,
we're eating at the same spot
and he's like, yeah, man, flu,
Chuck Ladell beat me up,
beat them down.
But we got in a fight in chocolate l
beat me up, hit him and knocked him down.
And I actually, yeah, that's what
happened. So that was a classic example.
And by the way,
you also,
something about while we're talking
about chocolate l uh, chuck,
when chuck has always been like awesome
to vets, especially wounded vets.
So chocolate l Yay.
If he's bouncing in a bar and you're
a vet and you get out of line,
you're going to get, you're going
get put down. But if you're a,
if you're a warrior,
that always impressed me about chuck
was he did some great stuff for the,
for the troops had been wounded overseas.
And that always gave me a lot
of respect for him. You know,
even more respect than I have for him
as being a great fighter. But anyways,
that kind of answers the question.
Um,
and so my overall broad guidance
here is train hard to do battle,
but do your battles in the gym?
Not In the street. It's, yeah.
It's only gonna get you either put in
jail or putting the hospital or both.
So I remember this guy we
trained with get his ear bit off,
remember? Yeah. Igor WPC. Yeah.
What's he in navy fill or is he, yeah,
he, he got out, but yes. Yes.
Yeah. He got into a street fight
and I mean he, he, he kicked the
guy's ass, right? He actually,
I think he more Thai clinch them,
put them down on the ground.
Got Cross side was kind of putting the,
putting the beat down on this
guy and the dude just big chunk,
big chunk of zero bigger than the chunk
that I'm bigger than chunked out Mike
Tyson to out. I mean, he was
a big chunk. I mean he's,
his ear is clearly has a bite taken
out of it. Like if you took a bite,
a big nice solid bite out of a piece of
pizza, that's what his ear looks like.
And you know, oh cool. You won the
fight, but you have no year left.
So that's a bummer.
And that's another thing that's another
point to that is that sometimes these
self defense type people
think that you know, oh I'll,
I'll call dries out. And
that's the indication that
I just kind of gave to that,
hey, the navy seal Mike,
do something tricky to you.
Well the bottom line is that stuff is,
a lot of times it doesn't work
and that's a perfect case.
The guy bit is you're often thinks,
oh, the guy's going to give up. No,
cause he's not giving up. He beat
that means he went even harbor, right?
That means,
oh,
now you've got a guy across the side
that's about to ruin your shoulder for the
rest of your life, for the
community, then put you to sleep.
And it's just a bad situation.
So you can't just another
thing about those,
those thinking that you don't need to
train because you're going to do an engine
mover. You're going to shove a cigarette
at some guy's nose, no wrong answer.
Or you're going to bite the rear off
and you're going to, no, that's not,
it's not true.
You need to train so that you can get in
those positions and that you won't lose
these fights. And also you need to train
so that you don't have to get in fights.
Because most of the time when you're
getting to fights because your ego is
getting out of control and you can't send,
you can't handle it in your little brain.
You get all,
get all insecure about who you
are as a man. So you think of,
we've kicked this guy's ass and then
you're either getting your ass kicked,
you're getting put in the hospital,
or you're going to jail or you've got
a big lawsuit against you. So be smart.
Yeah, that's rough. Hey, remember
I'm bloodsport when he was like,
you know the coin,
you actually bill that,
remember blessing that the guy with
the coin and he's like, hey, you know,
whenever I'm gonna, if I can grab
it before you close your hand.
And the girl had something to
do with it and then he's like,
he grabs it, he closed. Then
he's like, ah, you know,
I still feel the coin in my hand kind of
thing. He looks, he switched the coin.
That's kind of what your friend did with
a cigarette when he shoved it in the
guy sinus cavity. Cause it's like
super fast, you know and but precise.
But you can't count on that move.
And that's my point. All right,
kicking it off.
Let's go to question
number two shoe Jocko.
What if I don't have time to explain
the why to my troops for decision I'm,
I'm making during an operation
US army first lieutenant.
So awesome. Thanks for your
service. US Army First Lieutenant,
get some and I,
I talk about
troops and people in general
never wanting a pain,
a plan to be imposed upon them.
And so that's,
that's what this question is kind of based
around. Cause I'm going to say, look,
do you know you don't want to just force
people to do some plan. You want to say,
Hey, what do you think you
should do? And Hey, here's,
here's what we're doing and
here's why we're doing it.
This is why it's important that gets
people to take ownership of it and
therefore they do a better job.
So he must have heard me say that.
Now he's saying,
look,
sometimes I ain't got time to begin
to be explained in the why when we're
getting this going on.
And that's why this idea of explaining
the why is true 99% of the time in an
administrative situation,
in a situation where things are under
control and we've got time to think about
what's happening, that's when you can go
and say, Hey, what's your, what's your,
you know, what do you think? How
do you think we should do this?
This is why I want to accomplish this.
This is the commander's intent.
You can do it and all that stuff.
And that makes sense. Again,
in a administrative situation when there's
chaos and when there's May Hamot and
when there's uncertainty,
actually the opposite is true.
You actually want your troops to
you.
They they want,
they want to see and hear
clear directives from you.
They want to know what they should
do in no uncertain terms. And it's,
you can think of situations where if
you've seen, let's say a car accident,
right? And you see people
that are kind of frazzled,
if someone steps up into that situation,
don't one's doing anything that
they're supposed to be doing.
If someone says steps up and says you
to start dragging that person over,
there you go. Call nine one one. They
actually teach that. You know, when you,
when you're learning about how
to handle a traumatic situations,
somebody needs to step up, step
back, take charge of the situation.
Everybody wants that to happen.
And that's true in a combat scenario.
Again,
this is different from when
we're in the rear and we're,
we're formulating a plan and were safely
going over whatever ideas we have.
And that's when you want to get impact,
input and feedback and
you let your subordinate
leadership come up with a plan.
That's all good. But that's not
true during, uh, like I said,
during a pressure situation, when
there's a critical scenario unfolding,
people want to be led.
Now when you lead them
in those situations,
you can still give orders
by Commander's intent.
You can still just given tent.
So an example of that,
and I actually wrote my example down.
You can say like Delta one six,
we need high ground on the other
side of that road, make it happen.
So then the delta one,
six commander goes, okay,
I need high ground on the other side
of the road, there's a good building.
It looks like that. So we
can take, hey, you know,
squad come with me and they go over and
take down the building. I gave them a, uh,
still gave him commander's intent.
I gave him very clear commander's intent.
I didn't really tell them why. I didn't
say, Hey, what do you think would be best?
Do you think it's a good idea
to get high ground? No. I said,
go get high ground on the
other side of the street.
That's what I told them to do.
So I'm going to let them figure it out.
They understand what the intent is.
You could say something a
little bit more specific.
You could give them an actual, an
actual directive. You could say,
Charlie, one six Gig, take two squads,
assault building 34 on the
other side of the road.
Get high ground on the rooftop,
go.
Now we have something that's
more specific. Again, it's
not commander's intent,
it's directly I'm telling you what to do
and a lot of times people are going to
want that.
They're going to want to hear exactly
what to do in these pressers situations,
so depending on the level of experience
that your subordinate leadership has,
depends on maybe how specific you're
going to get with just given commander's
intent versus giving
something very specific to do.
Both of those are the right answers.
If you have a good really good leader
underneath you and you can just give them
the intent and you can let them come
up with a plan, cool. Go with that.
If you've got somebody that
needs a little more guidance,
give him a little bit
more specific guidance.
Now obviously,
one part of that is you got to have trust.
You got to have trust with the,
with the subordinate leadership
that you're working with,
whether that's you working with your
whole platoon and you just got to trust
your, your squad leaders and
your, your fire team leaders.
But you got to build that trust through,
through training and
through Harvard Training,
through coaching them and mentoring it.
And again,
I hate using the word coaching
and mentoring because that
always gives an air of
superiority and I'm not going to want
to come off across as superior to other
people. Mm hmm. Why do I not want to
come off as superior to other people?
Well, number one, because it, it
unifies our team more. And number two,
cause I'm not superior to
other people, right? Um,
another person and my subordinates,
even though they might not have as
much time in rank or experiences me,
they still might have great ideas
and I respect that. So this isn't a,
hey,
I don't want to use coach
or mentor because I'm
manipulating them and I want to
make sure that they,
that they listened to me because I'm
being a certain way with them. No, no.
I legitimately respect what they're
saying. That's the difference here.
So,
but that's my goal is to build trust.
And the other way that you build
trust enough said this before,
is by giving trust. You know, hey, I
trust that you can do this. Hey Echo,
you're going to go take down a building.
I trust your plan. Come up with it,
make it happen. Boom, you could do it.
You trust me more when I trust you,
you trust me.
And that's what we want to do now when
the operation is over and now you're in a
post operational debrief thing,
you can discuss why you gave a certain
order or you can get feedback from them
on why they executed in a certain way.
And you can get the questions going
back and forth and through that little
question and answer period that takes
place during a post operational debrief.
We get to know each other more,
we build more trust and we
become better as a team.
Hmm.
So that's the way it works.
You don't always have time to explain
why pressure situations you lead.
Yeah. Yeah. That trust
thing is big indeed.
Next question. Next question.
I like it. What do we got?
What advice do you have for
those who have weak, poor,
or otherwise ineffective leaders?
How do you manipulate that situation?
So again,
I think I may have actually
answered this question before
[inaudible], but I'll
answer it again. Sure.
When,
when you are in a situation this,
when you got somebody that's weak or
ineffective leader or a poor leader,
the answer's always the same.
Which news you lead,
you lead yourself and I hope people that
listen to podcast, all of the regular,
you all knew what I
was going to say there.
You all know that when
someone is not leading you,
then you lead them.
You pick up the slack for the weakness.
My leader want to come up
with a plan. Cool. I will.
My leader doesn't want to give
a brief. That's fine. I will.
My leader doesn't want to mentor
the younger troops. That's okay.
I will do it.
Leader doesn't want to take the
blame when something goes wrong.
That's fine with me.
I'm going to take the blame
and you think about that one. That one
can be tricky because you think, well,
I'm going to look bad in front of the,
in front of the more senior boss.
Now think about it from
the senior bosses position.
If if you work for me echo and
the boss comes in and we the,
the mission was a failure and I'm the,
and I'm the guy that's in charge
and I say, sorry boss, we failed.
It was echo's fault and echo
goes, hey sir, it was my
fault. Here's what happened,
here's the mistakes I made and here's
what we do to fix it next time.
Who Do you respect more? Yeah, of
course. I'm looking at promoting you.
I actually want to promote you and
our fire myself for being a guy that's
passing the buck and passing
responsibility, not taking
ownership of anything.
So imagine what that looks like before
you get all intimidated by taking the
blame for something and think you're going
to look bad and think you're going to
get fired. Think about what it looks
like from the senior perspective.
And you actually have to imagine
what it looked like underneath you.
You have to see it from your perspective
cause it's even when you think about
their perspective, you still
can be in fear of it. You Think,
oh I'm the guy that's taking the blame.
I'm the one that's going to get fired. No.
And am I saying this like blanket that
there's sometimes where if if the boss
screw something up really bad,
like let's say it was something like
classified information got left out and it
was your boss that literally left
it out and you go, no, it was me.
Well first of all, you're
not telling the truth. Right?
So you're not telling the truth and
the person made a mistake. That's that.
There's no excuse for, yeah. So that's
not a situation that I'm talking about.
And if your boss was the type
of person that said, yes,
I'm going to put the blame on him, I
would burn them alive. But I'd be like,
actually, here's what really happened. So
I'm not talking about
that type of situation.
But when you're doing an operational
thing where there's mistakes that get made
and your boss is scared to take ownership
of them, take ownership of them,
not that you will win in
the long run. Um, now,
now here's the part that is crucial and
critical and the most challenging part
of this.
And that is when you step up and lead,
you want to make sure you weren't
stepping up and stepping on your leader.
You don't want to step into
their little spotlight.
You don't want to impose yourself
in their leadership limelight.
And Gloria, you don't want to do
that. You, you, you can't do that.
You want them to get the credit.
You don't want to have them be
intimidated by you in any way.
And this is hard because when you
start taking ownership for stuff,
it's very, it can be very, um,
intimidating for the person that's
above you because they think, Dang,
this guy just,
he's just a bold bastard than stepping
up and taking charge of stuff.
And they might get intimidated that.
So,
so what'd you have to do
is you have to do some,
some indirect maneuver warfare here.
And for instance,
if they don't want to,
if they don't want to come up with a plan,
maybe you start saying, hey
sir, what do you think of this?
Would this be a good plan?
And maybe if you're,
if they're not mentoring the younger
guys, maybe say, Hey, you know what?
I want to do this up. I want to spend
some time with the guys after work.
Do you mind if I have a
little session with them?
Kind of go over what we've learned
on last appointment? Or Hey,
about this new regulatory thing that's
come out in the business world and I want
to get our younger troops to know it.
Do you mind if I teach a class on that?
So you're, you're asking them permission
and you might even say, you know, hey,
I think it would look really good
for you too if we were doing this.
Do you want to make
them look good? Um, and
those are the ways that you do that.
You step up and lead,
but make sure you're not stepping
on your leader because that, that,
that could backfire.
And you could end up in a situation
where they feel intimidated and you're
getting put in the dog house or fired or
demoted or in trouble because they feel
intimidated by you.
So use caution if you have a good leader.
Some leaders just aren't that aggressive
and when you start getting aggressive,
they start,
they actually like the fact that you're
getting aggressive and they like, I mean,
I worked for some people that I love
the fact that I would take a step up and
take charge. They had no problem
with it because they were good,
confident leaders.
It's the insecure leader you have to
watch out for the insecure leader that's
worried about looking bad.
And that's another two to change
perspective. Again on this,
when you as a leader have somebody
that's stepping up and taking charge,
as you start feeling intimidated by it,
ask yourself why. It's probably your ego.
You're being a weak leader by being
intimidated by your subordinates.
If you're subordinate is doing your job
at doing it better than you let get step
up and start looking at how can
you go up the chain of command?
How can you look up and out? How,
what other areas can you focus on?
Since that leader has stepped up and is
making things happen, that's awesome.
That is awesome. We want that.
That's decentralized command.
That's building other leaders underneath
you, which is what your goal is.
A leader should always be,
and I'll tell ya, every time I see someone
that goes, oh, I got a weak leader.
I'm always like, lucky you. Lucky
you. Take advantage of that.
Take advantage of it.
Do whatever you want.
Do you have such not good opportunity
when you have a weak leader above, you?
Don't look at that.
Don't,
don't get all down trodden because they're
going to or just doesn't motivate you.
Awesome. Motivate yourself, get
char, get in charge of things,
take advantage of it. Make things happen.
It's awesome to have a weak leader.
I love it. Get after it. It's good to
give me so much mobility in my, in my,
in my job. Right. I'm so much more
mobility. Then if I've got someone, Hey,
if I've got someone that's as
strong leader, that's great too,
but weak leaders know factor, I'm going to
take advantage of it. Yeah. I feel like,
yes,
you got a weak leader and you're kind of,
you're not stepping up.
You're essentially allowing
that the group, the team,
the objectives to kind of fail in a way.
You're kind of allowing it and then
in a way to, depends on what you do,
but in a way you're kind of being like,
hey,
all right. You're allowing the
excuse to be valid. You know where,
which kind of makes it invalid really,
when you're like, Hey, I could step up,
but hey, it's the leaders for
as long as it's not my fault.
You know that my leader is
not that good. You know? It's,
you're really not taking much ownership.
Yeah.
You just point your finger at your
leader and say, this is a weak leader.
That's not what we do here.
Not what we do at all.
And the end of the Times
where I've had weak leaders,
I always took advantage of it.
Like I said one time,
and I've talked about this on the
podcast before we fired our leader. No,
we had a little mutiny that
only happened once for me.
But it happens that,
I mean I obviously,
I don't know all the details of that,
but in a way isn't that you just
stepping up and making it happen.
I mean that's really the basic
impending result. Like Dang, that's,
that's kind of where we're
going to arrive. That really
given us stepping up. If,
if that's how it goes down. That's
how it goes down. But you stepped up,
you solve the problem, they're the
problem then that was a problem.
There's your solution. Yes. Up
and down the chain of command.
You got to own it.
Yeah, for sure. Alright.
Jocko Exhibition Jocko.
Hmm.
Did you do anything ritualistically
to get yourself mentally prepared?
Focused and in the proper mindset?
So just before carrying out a mission
such as self talk music or other actions,
you know,
get yourself revved up pre operation
preparedness for the mental state.
So
people ask this and it's,
and it actually sounds like a
pretty cool question, right?
I mean it sounds like a
pretty cool question. I'm
sure people walk through that.
Um,
it's a lot of times because you
think seals and soldiers and marines must
have some kind of deep and incredibly
meaningful borderline religious ceremony
that they go to and through in order to
prepare their mind.
Ver Combat.
Maybe it's a,
maybe it's a meditation on the warrior
code or maybe it's an aggressive song to
peak your adrenaline.
Maybe it's a,
a breathing exercise.
We got a special breathing exercise that's
going to heighten my mental awareness
and there's even seals and I use that
term loosely that have written books on
that subject of, you know, this,
this warrior mindset and the navy
seal breathing techniques and the,
the visualization and things like that.
No,
I hate to spoil the romantic vision of the
mindful warrior poet,
but that actually,
that idea just, it does not what
happens and here's the reality.
Um,
first and foremost,
when you are in combat and you're
preparing for an operation,
you are freaking busy. You
are busy. You are planning,
you're doing coordination, you're doing
gear prep, you're doing briefings,
you're making all these adjustments and
changes to everything that's happening.
You don't eat.
We are scrambling around.
I was talking to laugh the
other day and there was a,
most of the time if we were going on,
on in the field on an operation,
we wouldn't be sleeping for 24 hours
before we went in the field. You know,
maybe we'd get two or three hours,
but it was a sleep deprivation before
we went in the field because of all the
planning and preparation
that needed to be done,
especially on the big operations
with battalion sized or,
or brigade sized operations.
There's so much planning and preparation
that needs to be done that you don't
have.
You're not just,
you're not just sitting around figuring
out what kind of mental prep you're
going to do. There's just last
minute detail. There's a phone call,
you got a place to higher
headquarters. There's a, uh,
a Deacon Fishkin document that
you got to prepare. You've got to,
you got to get stuff done.
So taking some,
some kind of meditative moments
to get in the right mindset.
It's just not happening. You just don't
have the time for it. Now that being said,
mindset, it is a part of combat, right?
And so how did I get in
the right mission mindset?
Well,
the mindset is not achieved in the
minutes or even hours before an operation
from,
you know,
chanting a mantra or
breathing or meditation or
listening to some song that's
going to get you in touch
with your warrior spirit.
The mindset is achieved in the the weeks
and the months and the years before
that specific operation commends us.
That's another thing that the,
the idea from that actually I was raised
on in the 90s in the seal teams was
like,
you are going to do a mission.
We used to joke about it
called the big Mish, right?
The big mission was going to come and
was going to be one mission, right?
And you could get, Hey,
we're going to plan for it.
We're going to plan for it for weeks,
maybe even months,
and we're going to be able to visualize
everything. And we'd have all this time,
but reality is overseas. You
don't. Since the war started, man,
you're doing an operation every night.
You're going out, you've got another week.
Come back.
You're planning for that one.
When that one gets canceled
for whatever reason,
there's two more that you're playing
in four and you're running out to grab
intelligence, your meet with somebody
else. It's just constantly ongoing,
so we weren't ever preparing for
one mission. We were planning,
we were preparing for mission after
mission. We'd have five, six, seven,
10 we'd have 10 operations in the hopper
at any given time that we're planning
and preparing for. We're gathering
intelligence for, we're setting up,
we're doing route studies for four or
five different operations at one time.
Then finally one rise to the occasion.
Boom.
We're going to go hit that one the next
night, and another one's up to the top.
We're going to go hit
that one. Okay, so again,
this idea that I think came
from the nineties of, Hey,
we're going to do the big mish.
Yeah,
we're going to have to get into mental
mindset. No, we lived in a mental mindset,
but that mindset came from the
training that we went through.
The grueling training through the
repetition of the fundamental skill sets.
The mindset comes from the discipline,
from waking up early,
from studying tactics,
from understanding the enemy,
from all those,
yeah.
Unmitigated daily disciplines.
That's where the mindset
comes with it comes from,
and I'll tell you on top of that,
on top of that,
you have to come to grip with some
pretty horrific potential outcomes,
right.
You have to accept some
solemn possibilities like
that you might be severely
wounded or that you might be killed.
And you also have to
think that about the guys.
You're your friends.
That is a nother possibility
that you have to think about.
But for yourself,
you know,
okay,
you have to accept that possibility.
You have to accept that potential outcome
that you could die and you have to
accept that now you don't want it.
Yeah,
of course you want to live,
but you have to accept the fact
that in the game,
the game of combat,
you could very well die.
And I do that
and I was okay with it.
But,
but I had come to that conclusion a long
time before whatever operation I was
getting to roll out on one particular
night during a six month long deployment.
Hmm.
So the mindset is built over time and
like knowledge that you have the mindset,
it becomes so ingrained that knowledge
becomes so ingrained that you don't have
to cram for it.
Like you'd cram for a final exam.
You don't have to cram for the
test to combat in the last minute.
You already know you
already have the confidence,
you know you've done everything
possible to prepare mentally to prepare
physically to prepare emotionally.
Okay.
And then when the call comes and you
put on your cammies and you fill up your
canteens and you put on your helmet
and you lock down your night vision,
you lock and load your
weapon to roll out the gate.
You're ready.
You ever seen the movie gone
in 60 seconds, smell living?
No movies that you've
seen written on a stature.
There's a part where there a button there,
their car jackers team of car thieves.
They got to do this mission to save the
brother. You know, they're all retired.
That's why I said, but they got to do this
one last mission. So it'd be big Mesh.
The big miss you have. Exactly. So they
go through with it and get into a mindset.
So check it out.
Imagine if in the movie they were
doing that mission every single night.
I'm not going through that drill every
night because they know they prepared,
they know they've got their mind right
and they're gonna go out and execute the
operation. That's the difference. Or
maybe they would do it every night.
This is what they do. All right, let's
hear it. Paint, put it on low rider.
You know the song.
Yeah.
[inaudible] then they just
kind of listened to it and
then they go super subtle.
Yeah. Maybe check it out. Yeah.
You know, some guys, you know,
crank up a song. You know, we had
speaker, we actually had speakers outside.
Sometimes the guys would be blasting
some music, but it wasn't old,
like a ritualistic thing
where we all sat there,
closed her eyes and listen to the same
song at the same time meet. Yeah. Yeah.
Well yeah, I mean, and you know what,
I was always either what my two combat
deployments, I was a platoon commander,
I was task in your commander so,
well I was busy. You know, I was,
all that planning stuff that I'm talking
about was, was me. If I was going out,
if I wasn't going out then I wasn't doing
anything ritualistically to get ready
to go out. Um, but you're busy.
People don't understand
how busy you are in combat,
not just while you're on the battlefield,
but when you're back in the rear, uh,
preparing to go or preparing or
planning for operations. Yeah,
I would imagine some people, you
know, cause even list them all.
I mean really how deep, how far do you
want to stretch the word? Like ritual,
right. So that I'm sure some people
would write maybe like, like I said, kid,
like a lucky thing or I don't
know if you keep the carried lots.
Now you're getting a different realm here.
You're talking about superstition.
Well you're also talking about, so I had
certain patterns that I followed, right?
Yeah. Those patterns were
not for my mental state. They
were to be prepared. Right.
But it's kind of,
you know,
I've talked about how I had to caught
filled with my gear and when I put all
that gear on I was ready.
Right. That's, that's, that's,
and I put the gear on the same way every
time because you're going through a
process and a procedure so that you
make sure you get everything right.
Even when I'm coming to the record,
the podcast,
I do the same thing every
time I get this ready,
I get that ready to print this stuff
out. I, you know, I bring the same pens,
the same stupid pens.
I bring them all the time cause I
have a pattern that I go through set.
I'm ready for what we're going to do.
That's a standard operating procedure
to be ready for the operation.
Whether it gets me to mental state.
Yeah, I guess it does. Good Mental Stan.
Technically that is a ritual then
I guess on Boston. No, no, no, no.
You're the man of course.
For sure. Up Busted. But no,
I think I am in Boston because that is
definitely a ritualistic thing to go
through. And if I talk about,
uh, being in combat, sure.
Where you're getting your gear on,
you're [inaudible], you know, you're,
you're programming your radio, you're
getting radio check theirs. But again,
the reason it doesn't really hit me as
a ritualistic thing because those are,
those are standard procedures that
you're going to prepare for the mission.
You're not there physical
things that have to be done.
They're not for mental preparation.
Now does your mind no. What's coming?
Yes. And I'll tell you a classic example
is when you put down your night vision,
which for those of you
who don't understand this,
we have a helmet on and you
have night vision on it.
It can flip up where you're just
looking for your regular eyes.
But then when you black out the vehicles
and your flip your night vision down,
you're in a different world.
You're in a green world of darkness
where you know what's about to,
you're about to do.
So whenever I flip my night vision down,
he would always give me a a sensation.
Again, it wasn't this is preparing me.
I knew that it was time. Right. There's a
difference. There's a subtle difference.
No difference, no there. I'm sure
there is a different, but there's some,
there's overlap there. Where I
think that is, I mean, like I said,
it depends how loose you want to use
the word ritual, but technically yet,
like remember you said one time,
he said something about
before you guys rolled out.
Everyone starts there in the
same time ritual and ritual,
however, standard operating
procedures, it's a functional thing.
Like you've got to put your night vision
goggles down. You have to do that. You,
it's what you're going to
do and when you do that,
because you've done it a hundred times
before, you know that that's now game on.
But if, if you're just putting
your night vision goggles done,
that's not really the ritual.
But if it's like,
I'm going to put my night vision goggles
down after I do this every single time,
that's a ritual. Or we all do it
together. Like when it's, you're calling
it a ritual, you're putting a, you're
putting a ritualistic flavor to it.
It's a standard operating procedure.
They can be processed.
But I'm saying it's not
ritualistic because there was no,
um,
embedded deeper meaning that
was put on top of it purposely.
Very ceremonial.
We're trying to make it,
we're trying to make it in
someone's not right. Right.
Do you follow the same standard
operating procedures? Yes. So you and,
and you know, when we talk
about fighters, you know,
I've been with a lot of fighters and,
and coached him and those guys have
little ritualistic things to get.
Sometimes it is music,
right?
Because they're going to go fight a
five minute round and they're going to
listen to something or they're going to,
they're going to sit there and close their
eyes and think about what's important
to them. That's fine. I'm
telling you, when I was overseas,
I didn't have time to do any of that.
We were running around.
Never once did I say standby,
Hey,
no one talked to me for the next three
minutes while I get in the zone. Yeah, no,
I was in the zone because I
spent my, you know, did a workup,
did spent my time in the
teams, went through training,
you know, shot my gun, knew,
knew what I was doing and so I
didn't need to get in the zone.
And I think that's what I think.
That's why I think I'm sensitive to this.
And here's why I think
I'm sensitive to this.
I think I'm sensitive to this
because I think people try and,
and tell,
tell people or sell people on the
fact that if you do these things,
it will prepare you mentally for,
you know,
a pressure situation.
And that's what bothers me about it.
That's what bothers me about
it is, hey, if you do this,
if you, this is what it is.
If you take this shortcut,
then you will be prepared.
Because I would never tell someone,
oh, you want to fight an MMA fight?
You're going to get in the cage. Cool.
Here's what you need to do to train for
that three minutes before you enter the
cage,
go into his room,
shut your eyes and think about
how you're going to win the fight.
That is not true. Now this is, I
guess this is where you've just,
you've just gotten this out of me. Echo
you took me to, to, to my point that I,
that I believe in, right? That is
not what prepares you for the fight.
What prepares you for the fight is the
years and years of training that you've
done to get there.
The last three minutes.
You can have a ritual and it can
put your mind in the right place,
but that's not what's putting
your riding in the right place.
And what's putting your mind in the
right place is the months and months and
years of training. Same thing with on
the battlefield. If someone said, hey,
I'm about to go execute a,
uh,
a direct action mission and what should
I do to prepare for that? I wouldn't say,
well, what you need to do is listen
to your favorite an odor head song.
No, that is not going to help you. What
you need to do is you need to do this,
you need to go this shooting. You need
to work on these types of tactics.
You need to understand what to
do when someone gets wounded.
You need to have standard operating
procedures for how to go into an out of
buildings. You need to understand
how to clear rooms with open doors,
closed doors,
corner fed rooms,
all of these different things
that you need to know. You know,
I would tell you all of that stuff, but
what I don't like is when someone says,
oh, what you need to do
to be ready is do these,
do this last fraction of a thing,
and that's what's going to prepare
you for combat. No, not true. Yeah.
What prepares you for combat?
What prepares you for a fight?
What prepares you for a
tough business decision?
What prepares you for a pressure scenario
that you're going into isn't the three
minutes before?
That's the icing on the cake.
So I don't want to focus on that.
I want to focus on the daily disciplines
for months and weeks and years.
That led you up to the point so that
when I went in combat for the first time
and, and, and shot my
gun for the first time,
it wasn't about the
song that I listened to.
It wasn't about the briefing that I did.
It was the discipline and the
training that got me there.
So maybe I was a little bit hard
coming out of the gate on this idea,
but that's what,
that's why it was hard and I didn't really
understand that in my own mind until
you started bleeding me down this
road because that stuff does,
when I see somebody trying to sell
that, I don't like that. Yeah,
I don't like that. Do I have rituals? Yes.
I absolutely do not even have rituals
for when I get up in the morning and what
I do. You know, I, I fill my water bottle,
my water bottle every night when I go
to bed and he's in the same spot when I
get up out of bed in the morning, my water
bottles there, I put my, you know, I,
I'd go very quietly in the
bathroom and we talk about this.
I do what I gotta do in there.
I come out, I grabbed it's dark,
I grabbed my water bottle.
It's already where I know it's gonna be.
I need you to turn on any
lights. It's where it's
supposed to be. That's a ritual.
I go to the kitchen,
it's dark in the kitchen.
I fill up the water bottle by sound
cause you know how this little beautiful
sound as it fills up, it gets higher
and higher and higher and then boom,
you kill it. Now I walk out, I flip
on a light in the back of the house,
put the shoes on because
I'm not bothering anyone.
So there's a little ritual there.
When I walk up to the gym,
plugging the music and now it's time to
get after it. So there's a ritual there.
There's, there's, even when I
go to the gym and do Jujitsu,
I have a little ritual that I follow.
There I go, man. I taped the fingers.
I do what I gotta do for those youth
people that are going to ask. I taped the,
the, the two fingers on my
right hand, my pinky and my,
and my ring finger on my right hand
because my pinkies has got a little judo
finger. Right. So I, I
taped those two together.
It also gives me a little bit of
that friction on the guillotine.
At least that's what I've told Echo to
further intimidate and scare him of the
GT. So there's some little
ritualistic things there.
If Dean's there,
when I'll go in the sauna for five minutes
and just get a little bit warm before
he,
and he sees me sweating.
He doesn't like to see me sweating cause
he knows that, that I'm, it's on, it's on,
right.
So I'll go in there just to send a little
mental vibe to Dean that you know what
Jack was already sweating. He says, Damn.
So those ritualistic things,
those are the fraction,
the tiniest part of what you need
to do to prepare the preparation.
The mindset doesn't come from
those things. You want to,
you want to close out that final bit and
make it something ritualistic that gets
you in the right mindset. Do
it. But that not where the money
is made,
the money is made in the,
everything that leads up to those final
three minutes or two minutes or five
minutes of ritualistic behavior that you
have to get you ready to rock and roll.
So bring it.
What can we extrapolate there?
So the question is no really,
I mean you maintained really cause
the question is do you do anything
ritualistically to get yourself mentally
prepared? Focus and proper mindsets.
So you don't, but you do do things that
are rituals. But that's not the question.
This is one of the question.
So you're the rituals you're
talking about in regards to,
Oh yeah, Richard is, do I have,
what rituals did I have in, in, in,
in preparing for combat, training
my ass off, being prepared,
studying the enemy, being in crop,
physical condition, those, the rituals,
the rituals are the training
and the rituals that, like
I said, for the 20th time,
that little tiny thing, those are
just standard operating procedures.
And when you do those ritualistically,
then you're then you number one,
you won't forget anything.
You'll know that you have all your gear,
you'll know that you've done what you're
supposed to do and when you put your
night vision goggles down, you'll know
that it's on the straight and you'll be,
men are mentally prepared.
So your standard operating procedures
are rituals by technicality.
Sure, sure. There you though,
if for those of you that aren't
watching this on youtube,
echo just looked extremely proud of the,
of the statement right there.
I wasn't malady. They are, I'm proud.
I'm proud that I had some influence.
I don't want to completely beat
a dead horse. Um, because, but,
but what bothers me about that idea is
people thinking they can cut corners on
the preparation. You can't
cut corners. That's my point.
You can't cut corners and think you're
going to get the three minute preparation
to be ready for combat,
to be ready for battle for,
you'll be ready for a pressure situation
to be ready for a tough business
decision. You don't get ready
for that in three minutes.
You get ready for that for months and
years. That's how you prepare for it, bro.
I was, I used to play football
at Uah and we had this,
I don't know if you're watching like
football Bragg. No, I'm not. No,
I'm not laying down the set.
We already knew that though.
Anyway,
so I was a wide receiver and for the
drill wide receiver I was a lot smaller
back then. I was like one 81
85, whatever. Nonetheless,
one of the drills was this, um, if you
know football camp, you'll know this.
It's like it's a motor on a big tripod
and on the motor or the spinning tires
and they spin this way is too,
there's three of them.
So this they go on this
weird skewed angle.
So basically you load a football from
the back and you push it through and it
shoots the ball like, yeah. And there's
different speeds and stuff like that.
So uh, my coach, what was
his name, put you miles
my, I forget if that was his first
name or last name. Anyway, coach miles,
he wasn't very nice coach so
he would like drill us with it.
Right. Which is fine. That part is
cool cause it's training. But the,
the part that I didn't think was very
cool was if you missed like there was,
you would pay a price.
Like he would yell at you,
he'd sometimes he'd make you run it.
Like if you missed,
it wasn't like it was like, to
me the punishment, it was wrong.
Like the system was wrong,
their punishment didn't
fit the crime well. Yeah.
It wasn't like this isn't going to make
you better to put more pressure on this
drill. You know, it was more like, Hey,
look, eh, but he wants to cause stress.
Okay. Okay, good, good. I didn't feel
that at the time. And now, I mean,
I'd have to think about it more.
I haven't thought about
it and write your essays.
Your viewpoint would be different
maybe, but maybe not though. No, no,
I don't think so.
Only because I think that you're trying
to get the best out of these people.
You know,
for a specific game day,
there's been a lot of pressure and you
can actually get used to that stress by
inoculating yourself to it by him saying,
look,
you've got to catch this ball or
you're going to pay the man. Yeah.
Or just get better at
catching so you can know.
So you could focus on getting better at
taking stress or get getting better at
catching.
Okay.
We'll give you focusing now what I would
say is that he should have combined
both of them and he should have given
you guys ample time to just practice the
coaching part and then later distress.
That would've been great if he did that.
In fact is he did nuts. So back to the
ritual, mental preparation, whatever.
So thou,
it would be stressful for me as a young,
I was like 17 when I started
footballs, you know, late anyway.
So I'm like one of the
young guys and heat.
And so when he do stuff like to make
it harder and harder and harder.
So of course you're gonna Miss.
So there's this one where he's like ball
and then you know you're supposed to
turn it on the balls on its way,
full speed.
Things like in thing
comes real hard anyway.
So you'd miss and then he'd get on
that. So anyway, I'm stressed now.
It was not every practice I'm going to
and stress about that one drill that
we're going to do. So before
practice we had this cool, real,
real nice facility.
There's this lounge where I want to just
kind of cruise and mellow out cause he
goes,
you know,
from class to pre-practice
prep and then some meetings.
And then practice is a little bit of
downtime where you can mellow out in the
lunch. So in the lounge, I'd close my
eyes a lot of the time and be like,
just visualize that ball only for the
drill. Not In scrimmage time screaming.
I have no problem, but I'm visual,
I'm mentally preparing for the drill.
It just doesn't seem right anyway.
So yeah,
mentally,
mentally visualizing the ball coming
at crazy speeds and I'm catching him,
pull him, catch him off my
in my little visualization.
So I go and as time went on,
I kept doing that over and over and over.
Didn't help to drill at all.
Full failed.
Like as far as any kind of effect, I
would catch some miss, some get yelled at,
more stress next to him, even worse.
Same thing. So I, I would say this, first
of all,
visualization of uh,
a physical technique is proven to
help. So it didn't help. In your case,
what I would have said would have been
the most helpful for you is to say,
you know what? I don't care
what this guy does to me. Yeah.
I don't care if I miss this ball.
Mama, go out there and have fun. Yeah.
You want me to do?
It's not going to act like a maniac.
I'm going to have such a good
time running down the field.
I know what he calls ball.
I'm going to turn around and do my best
to grab that thing. If I don't grab it,
I'm going to do 14 somersaults and I'm
going to have a good time and so that
would you,
you're taking the pressure off yourself
because that's probably what was what
was a GM and you up this
you'd like to say it.
I don't say this to back
to this whole idea, right?
Another thing that that I,
that I feel this sort of allergy to this
type of thing is it's sort of like a,
on the Tim Ferris episode where
I was just answering questions,
I'm going to ask about motivation and
I said like, look, motivation isn't,
isn't your friend, right?
Motivations going to go up and down.
I feel like you know what's going to
be good is discipline, discipline.
And so there's really,
that's the difference between what I'm
talking about here when we're talking
about, hey, what do you do to get into
mindset? Well that's really talking about,
you know, your mental
mindset of motivation. No,
but what I'm talking about is discipline,
standard operating procedures
that actually prepare you
for what you're about to
do.
Not that motivate you temporarily by
listening to a good song or by doing some
breathing drill that gets you mentally.
But no,
the discipline is what's going to make
you mentally prepared for what's about to
happen. So again, that's why I think I'm,
I'm a little bit stuck in a mud on this
one and I'm trying to have an open mind,
but I think those are the
key components for me.
I don't like when people try and sell
shortcuts on stuff and make it, you know,
hey, you'll be great if you do these
three minutes. No, actually you won't.
You need to do everything else.
You need to do the hard work. Yeah.
And people buy into that. Why did they
buy into that? Because they want to take,
everyone wants the quick and easy,
you know,
I mean people that listen to
this podcast don't. Yeah. Right.
And the people that are here, we want
to get in the game fully. Two hours.
Two hours in a book. Yes. Yeah.
No shortcuts. No shortcuts.
So I think that's the
difference is people,
some people sell that and there's too
many people that buy into it when what
they should be buying is hey hard work
and dedication and discipline is what's
going to mentally prepare me. Not
this other stuff. Yeah. At the end.
Yeah. So yeah. So really like I said, the
sop bite by technicality, it's a ritual.
But here's the thing about it being only
technically or ritual because if you
take that away,
okay.
Not necessarily the SLP cause that has
a full on function. You know what to,
I hate to cut you off just
to talk about what we just,
what we're talking about here.
Right.
Cause cause I said hey with the
podcast and I've said this before,
we have a ritual that I do. I, you do
it too. When I come, I brew the tea,
I'm gonna put my hat, my pens, and I do
the folder, I print the stuff out. I have,
I put, put the knives in the bag.
I have a ritual that I go through,
but to case in point,
case in point,
that is not what prepares
me for the episode.
That is not what prepares
me for the recording.
What prepares me for the recording is
what w is spending 10 hours, 12 hours,
15 hours diving into a book,
looking up words. I don't know,
doing background studies on battles that
I don't understand that are mentioned
offhand, researching some general that
gets mentioned. That's what prepares me.
That's what gets me in the mindset
to record a podcast, not the ritual.
The ritual doesn't actually mean anything
without that core deep preparation
that's done. And that kind of
settles our point here. Yeah,
I by no mean very nicely.
Yeah, I was going straight
technical. And you,
I think you're absolutely correct.
And sometimes because I would fall like,
especially when you're young and you're
like, just anything that'll help me,
you know, like do I, did I tie
my shoes in the wrong, you know,
like superstition goes in
there. You don't, you know,
that feeling where you're like, Dang,
you just stressed about something.
So anything that'll help. And then after
a while you kind of go to yourself, man,
it doesn't matter what order
I put my shoes on right now.
It doesn't matter what color my
socks are, you know, you know, man,
I used to have this thing where I'd be
stressed to go to school for whatever it
is. Like intermediate skin.
When you're like a news glue,
it's just a little bit stressed,
not full on,
but still is looking for a little thing.
So it's this weird even thinking
about her in a so weird. Um,
so I'd have a, you know, music
in your car on a tape. So
I liked Bushwick bill, who's a
rapper and Geto boys. Anyway. No.
So, and it had, you know, punch of
swearing in it, but it was just a great,
great album. And I liked it, but
I had it. We strangely in my mind,
if I listen to like negative stuff,
I'd have a negative day and
some people might say like,
well who that's going to true.
But no, I don't think so.
I think it doesn't matter
really what music you like.
Maybe my certain music might put you in
a certain mood, but that's up to you.
Yeah,
we're actually going in a whole nother
direction or which I'm fine with going
there. Um, I have always
found that music to me,
like the words and the music.
I'm barely registering what they are.
I know him. I'll be, it might even be
singing along with them in my mind,
but, but the words generally
aren't having a huge impact.
I mean I've listened to all kinds of
rock and roll music throughout my years.
If I would've followed,
followed along with 10% of the lyrics,
I would probably be a heroin addict
in the gutter somewhere. Right.
Cause you can't just listen to music
and obey. What they say. In fact,
you shouldn't do that. Most music is
a lot of music is negative, right?
I mean a lot of music is very
negative in what it's saying. So
yeah. So what you're saying is the ritual
of listening to the right music is an
important or not?
No, not important at all. I'm just
saying I used to like kind of,
I don't know if they fall for that trick,
but I young, I was like an intermediate
school. So you believed it.
You believed at the time.
If you listen to negative music you
might have a negative negative day. Yes.
And not the fame,
not the kind of where it's like I'm going
to listen to this and then I choose to
go.
This will fire me up to do what I,
it wasn't that it was a
superstition is what it was.
And I'm saying my point for the whole
thing is you don't like how people like
basically hang their success or failure
on some Ma visualization or some ritual
and agree.
Then that the point I'm making is I
would have to like remind myself of that.
Like men,
the music,
like nothing bad's going to happen to
me because I listened to Bushwick Bill.
Talk about this thing that
I will say this though.
That is a conscious decision
that you made. Yeah.
Whereas if you were just listening,
I mean music changes your mood.
Music changes my mood for sure.
Yeah.
And when I hear certain music I get a
certain reaction to it and I will get into
a certain emotional state before I'm
listening to a song that's about something
or not something else, you know,
that will have an effect on me now.
I don't know that.
My point is that eat the lyrics themselves
don't really mean anything I guess.
I guess if they do mean something though,
and they hit me a certain way,
music definitely will put you in a
different mood in my opinion. Yeah.
If you let it,
like if you're using it well I would
say put you in a mood unless you don't,
don't let it. Yeah. Cause if
you just listen to it now,
there's times where you listen to whatever
music and it's just not going to hit
you. But some music that you have
might have a core, uh, fought about.
Now does this go back and
negate my earlier point?
That music doesn't affect my mindset?
Does that do it?
Am I right now I'm going back on
what I said, cause I said, oh,
music doesn't affect your mindset. Uh,
I guess I am going to though. Yeah.
But ultimately I think,
I think really it holds up where you look,
here's the deal,
here's the deal.
You're going into a stressful combat
situation and you didn't get a chance to
listen to your song. Can you
afford to be like, oh no, I
can't go. No. So that's why,
that's another reason why yes, I'm staying
with my original point. Yeah, I agree.
I agree with you. Let's stick with it.
Don't let anyone sway you. Don't let them,
it's still a real bite
technicality though. Jocko.
Is this question number five now or can
you speak about winging it and when it's
best to just go for it and when making
a plan without the time to do still is
the best course. Okay. Yeah, I can
definitely talk about that. Um,
well winging it is never the first choice.
And when,
when you see people in the,
in the seal teams are in the military,
if they're winging something,
it's something that
they've practiced a lot.
If it's something that they have planned
Broglie before and they've so much
experience in that,
whatever that type of operation that they
can actually get away with it. Right?
And a good example, if you take a Jiu
Jitsu example like dean lister, he
can wing it in a match.
Jeff Glover can do that to a ridiculous
level of just winging it in competition
and just show up and just do what
he does because he's got, you know,
those guys at that high level have a
mental fluidity that's going to be very
helpful for them.
Now there's other people that are very
high level Jujitsu players that don't
wing it,
that are very much more methodical.
And I'm sure there's some cases with
both Jeff and dean where they probably
should have been more methodical.
But I mean Jeff has straight up
suicidal in many of his matches. I mean,
and that's what's beautiful is,
is that he moves so much so rapidly
that people can't hang with him on that
level in most cases. Um, so that's
why he, he, he is winging it.
Like every movement that he makes
is winging it. But case in point,
he's puts himself in those
situations all the time.
You come to the gym and watch them train.
He's letting people put him in the worst
possible situations and figuring a way
out of it. So the reason he can wing it
in the competitions, cause he's, he's,
he's put putting practice and discipline,
they're in the background and if you
saw my seal platoon or tasking it,
we could wing it on operations all the
time because we were prepared because we
knew each other so well because we
had standard operating procedures that
covered so much of the things that would
happen during an operation where we
would be quote unquote winging it.
So even though we're winging it,
we're not really winging it because
we have all these standard standard
operating procedures in place that
we didn't really need to plan.
But if you have time to
plan and of course plan,
do as much planning as you can,
dig in and plan every
detail that you can plan.
Now
when it does come to planning,
I think the most important part of a plan,
the thing that makes a plan the most
effective is its flexibility and making a
plan that is so flexible that when you
do the actual operation and you come up
against unexpected things which
are absolutely going to happen,
you have the flexibility,
you have options,
you have contingency plans to deal
with now so plan as much as you can.
But the problem is with all that
emphasis on planning and sometimes people
become obsessed with planning and they
plan and they plan and they plan some
more and they plan and they plan and plan
and they don't want to execute and if
they do execute,
they execute late.
They missed their opportunity. So
that's why, that's why Patton said,
I got this note written down here.
Patents at a good plan violently executed
now is better than a perfect plan
executed next week. Right.
That's what we're talking about.
He's come up with a good plan.
Don't come up with the perfect plan that
takes you two weeks to come up with.
That's not going to help you.
That's something you need to keep in
the front of your mind and that is
especially applicable in a tactical
decision that's being made in the field,
right? Something that is unfolding.
You see the enemy maneuvering.
You come up with a quick plan and you
execute because every minute that you're
waiting to execute,
the enemy is maneuvering on you
that that low in enemy fire.
That's not them retreating and running
away. No. Your mindset has to be that.
That's them maneuvering on you.
They're getting a better position.
They're setting up, getting ready to
crush you, so don't let that happen.
Make a plan and go in.
That comes back again to flexibility.
If you come up with a good plan and
you go, as that plan is being executed,
you got to pay attention.
You've got to pay attention and watch
how it's unfolding it don't put the
blinders on and you've got your
plan and now we're going to go on.
We're not going to look around anymore.
We're just gonna follow the plan. No,
you have to be observant. You
have to observe, Orient, decide,
and act the whole time.
You can't just come up with a plan and
stay on that track because when you come
up with a fast plan,
you're not going to have thought about
every single detail and you don't know
what the enemy's going to do anyways.
You don't know what your competitor is
going to do. You can't guarantee that.
So when you see them start to
react to your, what you executed,
now you've got to be ready to
react yourself and get the art,
the the upper hand and take the offensive.
So
there's an,
there's one more.
There's one more little dichotomy to this,
and
I'll just say it,
even though I'm saying you got to adapt
your plan and you need to adjust as
things happen,
you also want to stick to your point.
Those things are completely the
opposite of each other, right?
I'm saying adapt and
change your plan as needed,
but I'm also telling you to stick
to your plan. But for instance,
if you rehearsed a,
or if you have a standard operating
procedure for your order of patrol.
So this is the, the order of, you
know, the point man, and it's,
it's Jones and then Smith and then
Washington and then Jefferson,
and that's your border patrol,
right?
And those guys were always marching in
that order. And so we know each other,
we know how to work together,
we have fire team integrity,
we have a standard operating procedure,
and we're going to attack a target.
And when we get closer to the target,
we see that, hey, you know what?
Maybe it'd be better to move this guy
over here and move this guy over here.
And so let's,
let's change our standard order of March,
our standard patrolling order,
because it'll,
it'll be easier when we get to the target.
Hmm.
Don't do that.
You have your standard
operating procedures are
for a reason. You have them.
And when you start pulling yourself out
of the standard operating procedures for
good reason, that's going to
come back and bite you. It's,
it's not gonna work out good.
So be flexible.
This is going to be an interesting
statement and be flexible but stick to the
plan but be ready to adjust but
stick to the plan and that's totally
contradictory and I know
that and I apologize,
but that is what leadership is.
Leadership is balancing those dichotomies
in leadership is knowing when, hey,
we stayed with our standard
operating procedure.
We're going to hold through it
through this little thing right here.
You know there's been, there's a little
small terrain feature we didn't expect.
We could change our plan right now and
adapt to that in the unlikely event that
or the the small chance that something
happens and we'll be better for it at
that moment. No, stay with your
standard operating procedure.
But then when something dramatic
happens and you need to make a change,
you do it aggressively, you
do it dynamically and then
you continue to observe,
Orient, decide and act and stick. Keep
beating the enemy inside the [inaudible]
Ooda loop.
That's it.
Next question, Jocko. Yes. An Echo.
Oh,
Bjj ex partner is training in another gym.
Now my head coach banned him
from coming back.
The question.
So dojo,
loyalty versus freedom.
Okay,
what up?
So there is some tradition
behind this actually. Yup.
And the tradition is actually
the attrition of the Crayon,
which means that's so crayon.
She is a, it's a Brazilian word
and it's a name, right? It's a,
it's a name from a character
in a Brazilian soap opera.
You're looking at me like you
didn't know that, did you? This,
I didn't know you didn't know this,
but of course everyone knows
[inaudible] Jitsu Korean. She came from,
it's a character in a Brazilian
soap opera that was like a,
a backstabber look. An
unloyal guide. Yeah. Right.
And so when,
especially back in the early
days for me in Jujitsu,
which was pretty early days in America
for Jujitsu in the 90s if anyone was
going from gym to gym or even left a
gym permanently to go to another gym,
they were labeled this horrible word.
It was the,
it was the worst thing you could call
somebody, right? It was like, yeah,
this guy's a crunchy. And that
meant that they were a trader. Yeah.
That's what it meant. And
there's also, so that's,
there's a tradition of it in Jujitsu,
right,
of this idea that if you change gyms
or you trained in a different place,
you're a coach. Now there's a
little backlash against that.
And there's people that have,
you know, I a matter of fact,
we used to joke about being
like team crayon. She was,
we were all training at different places
and trying to find the best places to
train. I, but there's,
beyond that, there's a,
there's a martial arts kind of
tradition as well, which is, you know,
loyalty and gratitude to your instructor,
right?
That's a, that's a fairly understood
tradition, not just in the martial arts,
but in any arena where you're learning
something from somebody that's putting
their time and effort into you
to instruct you in something.
And there's also a practical
level of reasoning behind this.
And that is competition,
right?
So if you're going to be competing and
you compete with a guy at your gym that's
got an unbelievable triangle,
and then somebody else comes from another
school and they are basically wrong
with that guy. And they said
he's got a really good triangle.
Now you're in a competition against
that guy. And he tells his buddy, hey,
that guy you're gonna compete against
has a really good triangle watch out for
is triangle. You know, that can change
the outcome of the match. You know,
the details of it and all that stuff that
can change the outcome of a match. So
there's a practical level to it. You
know, there's also sharing moves,
right?
And if certain schools might have a
really good series of moves are moves and
all of a sudden someone goes to,
you know, train somewhere else,
they can share that move.
And that's bad.
And you know what's interesting
is in every business,
most businesses that I work with, I should
say they have their own little worlds,
right? And they have their own
kind of loyalty and Crayon. She,
and if you, if you're at
you, you pick an industry,
people are good in that industry.
And when they change companies,
they bring with them the same kind of
thing. They bring maybe some secret sauce,
maybe some moves,
maybe they know some personalities,
they know the weakness of that
other company. So when they leave,
there's a loyalty factor
that comes into it. Now
that being said,
loyalty goes both ways.
And I've talked about this before.
The student should be loyal, right?
But the teacher has to be loyal as well.
That means they have to be teaching
solid stuff. That means they need to,
you know, train correctly. That means
they need to offer enough classes,
all kinds of things right there. The
teacher, oh, some loyalty to the students.
And on top of that,
on top of that,
this is America, right? This
is America. And in America,
you pay to go to a school.
You pay money, right?
It costs you money.
And I always use this example when
people ask me about this in America,
just because you normally get your pizza
from Domino's doesn't mean that if you
feel like you can't get to call up
little Caesar's and some common cause,
it's getting, it's America,
l. A. N. N. N. If guess what?
If little Caesars makes a better pizza,
you're going to maybe order even
more often. Yeah. So it's, there's,
there's competition,
right?
And you want to end up where you
get the best pizza and there's so,
so there's some advantages to looking
for that good pizza. There's, there's,
and there's some advantages to traveling
around and good training at different
places because you're
going to get different, um,
schools with different instructors that
have different specialties and different
styles
so that can be advantageous.
There's also some disadvantages to school.
They'll go into a bunch
of different schools.
Number one is your teacher
doesn't really know you,
so now your teacher
doesn't know your style,
doesn't know what moves
would be good for you.
They also don't see you progress because
you're only coming back every once in a
while.
And whenever they don't,
they don't see you getting
any better and they're not,
they're not really maybe as comfortable
teaching you everything because you're
not really their students. And you
know what man? It is a, it's a, it's a,
it's a powerful thing to teach
someone Jujitsu and him and it's,
it's an effort and there's
an emotional component to it.
When you teach somebody Jujitsu,
there's an emotional thing that you're
giving them something and there's an
emotional level in there somewhere
that says, you know what,
I'm giving you this.
Not going to hold it over your head,
but you know, there's this
little song from there. You,
I'm not going to say you owe me anything,
but you owe me a little something.
Wait, wait, like, like what
you like, so I taught you this.
So now you need to go and not mess it
up or you got to represent or is it like
don't use this to, I dunno.
I think what he means.
I think it's a little bit of both of,
you know, I'm investing all this in you,
right?
Sure you're giving me 100 bucks a month,
but what I'm giving you is worth
more than a hundred bucks a month.
Like we know that,
right?
So give me something back.
What do I want back and want you to train
with me? You know what I mean? Just, hey,
you going to go to another school
and you're going to train there.
Sometimes I understand
that, but oh, wait a second,
now I'm just your part time teacher.
Okay,
well I'm not going to invest very much
in you anymore. Right? So there's a,
there's an emotional
component to it. Now, again,
back to the advantages, because there's
a dichotomy of everything, right?
You're rolling with different
people at different schools. Like,
is it one thing that's nice
about our schools? We got, uh,
we got different instructors
with different styles. I mean,
between Dean and Jeff, they are literally
at the opposite end of the spectrum,
which is fricking awesome to have there
at the opposite ends of the spectrums of
the Jujitsu skillset. Right?
They're just crazy different.
They almost don't look like
they're doing the same sport.
And when I trained with both of them,
I don't feel like I'm doing
the same sport different.
It's just a totally different game.
But you've got James Nielsen
who's got his own style of Jujitsu,
which is insane. Uh, Greg train,
obviously you got him combinant hot,
whom I missing Adam.
He's teaching hose his own
little different style. Who
else? Jeff, Jeffrey Owl.
Jeffrey House got his bad ass game fast.
Me,
I don't know what I don't teach myself,
but I'm sure that there is a
different element there. Yeah.
But you coach up and stuff like
people learn from me. I know.
I like a lot of stuff I learned
from you, you know, and like
you're like, um, uh, to,
to tillage, whatever, you know, like
you train with Jeff all the time,
you're going to learn some real creative
dynamic stuff you learned from Dean,
you're going to learn a lot of stuff
like in, you know, in that way.
So I think a lot of people still,
even though you're not instructing you,
they do learn a lot from you. Yeah.
And I do teach from time to time.
Um, but yes, I do. And I do when I
teach, a lot of times when I'm teaching,
I might not be teaching the class.
Right, right. I'm saying, hey buddy,
go check this out. Yeah, it's over
here. So, so those are advantages.
If you were at a school
with one instructor,
then I could see where
you'd be going, man. Okay.
There could be an advantage if I go
try some other instructors. Again,
there's a trade off because now, now
you start learning something. I said,
I actually see this more with striking,
which with striking training where guys
that move around from different coach,
different striking instructors,
a lot they don't,
it's not like Jujitsu where you can
incorporate it in and you learn something
from some other guy and you bring it
into your game and you change it a little
bit. When I see people move
striking coaches a lot,
I see their game actually deteriorate
in my opinion because striking is more
instinctive. It's an
instinctive thing, right?
You're throwing your
combos and you let them go,
like you let your combos go and you react.
It's, it's just something that happens.
It's more mechanical,
so when you train mechanically to react
and to throw your combos the way you're
throwing them and then all of a sudden
you change that and you want to throw him
a different way.
I think it trips people up.
I think it sets them
backwards a little bit.
Whereas digital you can
incorporate new games,
different parts of games more fluidly.
And also striking when you're training,
striking, you did too short, you learn
moves from the Co, your instructor,
he learned, you know, some timing
stuff, but it's like instruction.
But then you have to
train with a multitude,
like all your training partners introduced
to and that's part of your training.
So if you go striking, it's
not really like that. In fact,
most strikers they'll stay,
they'll stick with one coach and then
they'll have a multitude of sparring
partners that changes. And Jujitsu just
by its own nature is already like that.
Yeah.
And when you spar against other people
striking though your fundamental
movements, they'll change a lot less
than they will when you're rolling.
We just took down a bunch of different
people using more of your body.
There's just striking
is linear. Yeah, morning. And
Jujitsu is completely not linear.
So therefore when you're
training something that's
linear and you start going
off that line,
it trips you up in my opinion.
But we do Jitsu, it can be
beneficial at times too. Um,
train with some other people.
Advantages and disadvantages.
So I guess to get to these question,
long winded answer,
um, one, you know,
what is it? The head coach banned him
from coming back. That's a bummer.
That's a bummer. I, I'm,
I'm sorry to hear that.
I've never banned anyone from our
school for going and training in another
school. Yeah. I'm not intimidated
by that. Right. If someone goes,
Hey, I'm going to go train it,
there's other school, I'm like, cool.
And they come back because they get
there and they go, okay, this is cool,
but I'm going to come back to where we
get this training that we have at victory.
Right.
Which I'm comfortable with.
And if someone goes somewhere
and goes and goes, oh,
I like this place better than victory.
That's cool. Good luck. I mean, it's all,
and you know, in a year they come back
and go, yeah, I'm coming back. You know,
I don't get mad at them because
everyone's on their own journey,
I guess you could say.
Everyone's finding their own path and I'm
not going to force people down a path.
I might recommend a path,
you know, I might say, you
know, and I do that, you know,
that's what, that's what we have the
gym for. It's like here's a path man.
And it's wide open.
It's a beautiful path with
incredible Jujitsu practitioners.
So I don't, I'm kind of bummed out
to here, you know? But that happens.
But I do understand and I
think that's what if I was,
if I were in that position where I'm at
a school and my training partner leaves
and then he gets banned that I
don't like that. I don't like that.
Yeah.
Let me get some,
yeah. I think security group and
hear everywhere is kind of different.
Here is kind of a situation here
in southern California. God,
especially in disability, Nicholas
situation, we got the Jujitsu everywhere.
Everywhere. Yes. So, and it's
literally on every street corner.
In some cases you can
literally walk comfortably,
comfortably. It's like one block to
the next one and it's a good one too.
That's the thing.
There's just a schools everywhere.
I'm sorry for those of you that live
in the non Jujitsu parks in the world,
I'm sorry,
we have a lot of g do her in San Diego
we have like our and southern California
in general. Orange County, la is crazy.
So you figure in San Diego what's going
to kind of be a result of that is like
our situation. For example, we
have dean who's kind of the,
the main guy who kinda came
in with the school, right?
Remember Dean had the small kind
of school do the boxing club,
came to throw down is what it was called,
became victory.
But with Dean was like a bunch
of guys like for Ileus. Um,
James, nils, nils thin.
Some other guys from Fabio Santos and
we all trained together at least was
instructor,
like all these guys.
And then some guys went and
open their own school now.
So not as a result of that whole
situation. Sure. We have other schools,
but they're kind of still are guys in a
weird way. There are different things.
So if I go train with the [inaudible],
which I Johnny for he another one
who my instructor for a little while,
I'll go treat with Johnny sometime.
And then w is that,
is that a fantasy situation? No.
Yeah. I mean even technically.
Is that a crunchy situation though?
You're asking me technically, I would say,
I would say back 10 years ago. Yeah.
That would be a major crouch situation.
Is it right now for me? No. I want you to
get better at Jujitsu, right? Yes or no.
And if,
if you got an opportunity to go,
you're going to be trained
at another school. That's
cool. Yeah. Cause it's, it's,
it's gonna make you better. It doesn't,
it doesn't offend me. You know what?
I'm not a jealous husband. Right.
I'm not jealous of, of that.
I don't think, oh, what if he
goes and never comes? I know you,
I know where it's at. Right.
And, and, and so it's all good.
You know who I'm coming home to them.
That's right. That's right. Well,
I think the culture just in general
is shifting. And I think this is this,
like in southern California,
it's going to be more like this,
like way more laid back. Of
course he get, you know, little,
little tiny little groups of people
who still believe that even though,
but the really the community like that,
in fact,
have you considered studio
five 40? That's a crayon. Ge,
GM might will be called Crayon, GE capital
all the way down to the instructors,
not Fabio Santos would teach
there one day if I'm just on,
just has his own gym by the
way. Arizona. Kevin, by the way,
same thing with the Higgs.
Like all these are guys who came from
other academies and they invite whoever
and they actually have other
fabulous currently. Yup.
You can go visit when I visit all the
time, you know, everyone knows each other.
So it's like the culture is different.
And I think,
I think with our gym it's not as,
uh, not as pronounced as that,
but we definitely, I mean, people come
in every day from, we're all over.
How many victims were represented today,
Matt?
There was guys from all over San Diego,
guys from all over the country, a victory,
you know, showing up from Seattle trooper
wanting to get his game on, you know.
Right on, you know I haven't tell
America yeah, that's right. These,
these mode up there. Yeah,
he was good and that,
and that's the cool thing you
said at Dean said it, he said,
I encourage you to go to other gyms or
I mean not to be some sweared spy big
Bro. If you want to go get training, cause
I was going up to Eddie Bravo's when,
this was long time ago when he,
when he was at like legends
and I was going up there
for work or whatever and um,
you know,
I knew about that or it's like,
oh is that kind of
backstabbing if I go train,
you didn't tell me that you
were doing that. Actually I do.
It wasn't about any brothers one,
but it was about something else.
I did tell you and he said the
same thing. He was like, Bro,
you get as much training as you
can, you know, if you want to,
if you want to be a part of this
association academy or whatever,
then up to you and
I'm glad you're here,
whatever,
and I don't think personally that you're
going to do it, but pray your care date,
learn Jujitsu. And if you can
learn some Jujitsu over there,
like more of a certain type, then you can
hear or anywhere, fine. Go do it. Yeah.
He said the moral juices you learn
the better. So I was like, Dang,
quit from Dean lister right there. Yeah.
That more digits or you learn the better.
Yeah.
And then,
and then so even to kind of go
above and beyond that is when you,
okay, well let's say, you know what
I got to when to interject here is,
especially for some of these academies out
there, men Jiu Jitsu it, it's like you,
you're a doctor because you went through
10 years of school to get your black
belt. Just like a doctor goes. And
what sucks is when you're a doctor,
you make x amount of money. It's a very
steady paycheck and you're kind of set.
Jujitsu doesn't mean anything.
That black belt that you worked
10 years for doesn't get you paid.
So the reason I'm saying this is some
of the people that are more defensive
about this, if they're an instructor and
they have a small academy, they need,
they, you're financially supporting
them. They worked hard to do that.
They've invested in you, they counting on
you. So when you just go, oh, you know,
I'm gonna go train somewhere else that,
that not only does it hurt them
emotionally, like I said, cause man,
when you put some effort into
somebody, you feel like, oh,
you're going to leave after I gave you
all of that and you didn't give it to him
cause you,
they paid,
but you gave them the value that you
get out of Jujitsu is not worth $100 a
month. It's worth $1,000 a month.
It's worth, it's worth a ton of money.
Keeling put that on his, uh, on,
on some social media posts that he,
because he got his black belt shoe and
when he did, he's like, well, you're rich.
When you got something that money can't
buy. And that's the truth, right? And,
but that black belt doesn't get you
any money. It doesn't mean anything.
So there's another component to this
whole thing that if you're leaving and
going to different schools and someone
thinking, Oh man, I'm going to lose,
you know, this is how I feed my,
there's, you know, Jujitsu is,
you want to become a Jujitsu instructor,
you're generally not going to become a
rich person, right? Not financially rich.
So there's that component too.
Now,
luckily we have a big gym and it's a
little easier for guys to come and go.
It's okay. You know, we're
not sweating it as bad. Um,
and yeah, so you gotta, you gotta
keep that in mind as well that your,
your coach that's poured more
than what you've paid them.
Because I don't just want to say,
hey look,
I'm paying for this instruction so you
owe it to me and I'll go do whatever I
want.
That's to base of a statement to make
truly Jujitsu has more value than the
hundred dollars a month you're paying
for it. Yeah, and you'd really,
as a quote unquote customer or member,
I mean everyone's different.
There's sure there's exceptions to this,
but generally you don't want that
anyway. Even if you think you do. Like I,
I sh I can be free to come and go and
technically you are free to come and go as
soon as you are,
but don't think that like everyone's
going to be just a hundred percent fine
with it all the time because
when, when you, when you come in,
like how you said like it's a kind of
a two way street, you would hopefully,
I hope my coach takes pride
in what he taught me for sure.
Hope my coaches like I care about
how good you become for sure.
I hope he's not the guy who's like,
give me the check,
I'll teach my moves and who
cares about how good you get an,
I don't want that guy. You don't
want that guy. Yep. So there is that.
And so that makes sense is
it is that two way street,
but as a competitor or a practitioner
guy learning as a student,
especially when you reach a certain level
and you've been training with kind of
the same,
even like 2025 guys will say you've been
training with these same 20 which is a
lot of guys, by the way, totally strained
with, you've been trained with them for,
I don't know, whatever, eight years we'll
say. And then you go to another gym, man,
that's a way different look. So it's
like fresh brand, new types of training,
you know, it's like you're
almost going to competition,
but you're not competing
because we need to compete.
You get to go against people who never
trained with before. Yeah. So yeah,
different guys, different. And
that's, aside from even the debt,
different teddy meetings. You know what
I find when I go into situations, when I,
when I trained with somebody that doesn't,
I don't train with all the time,
it's just you,
you feel a lot better at Jujitsu.
Cause they don't because they don't know
you're gay, you're gay and you know, we,
you know, everyone's got their
own little special thing.
So I always feel like a little
bit better when I go see it.
And that's part of my point where if
you train with 25 guys, those 25 guys,
they know your game. And not to say
it's not good drinks, good training,
but they know your game.
So it may not be as accurate as far as
like training competition or something
like that after a while. So when
you go to these new places you get,
that's an additional layer of,
of training.
You get another subject on this as a
kind of always bummed me out when I would
hear from my Jujitsu friends that have
we been in San Diego for 20 something
years and all of a sudden be like,
oh,
we can't come to your school because
our instructor doesn't want us to.
And I always be like, Bro, the,
yeah, that's, so that's like,
I wouldn't tell somebody that I'm
not trying to control people. Yeah.
And it bums me out.
So that actually brings up another subject
that I feel like I have to talk about
because we got a lot of people out there
that are starting Jujitsu for the first
time. A lot of troopers that are getting
in the Jujitsu game, which is awesome.
It's awesome. And I get a
lot of people saying, oh,
what school should I train at in wherever?
Throw a dart at a map in America.
And that's what they're asking me about.
First of all,
I don't know all those instructors.
Now generally, you know,
somebody that does Jujitsu,
we'll look at a website and see what
a guy's credentials are and say, yeah,
that guy looks like a legit
black belt or legit brown belt.
Or even a guy asked me the day,
is it worth learning from a purple belt
if there's no one else around them?
Like absolutely. Absolutely. So,
but people ask me about these schools
and I kind of give them my best guests.
Like, you know, I'll take a look
at the website and um, you know,
see if there's a backlog. You
don't need to ask me. By the way,
Google look at their record,
make sure that they do Brazilian Jujitsu,
not some other form of Jujitsu. Um, just,
just,
you can figure
it out. You don't need, you're going
to go to the school and assess.
But what I want,
the main point that I wanted to bring
up isn't that it's just this part here,
is that being into Jujitsu doesn't
mean that a person is a good person.
And being a black belt in Jujitsu
doesn't have anything to do with their
character as a person. And
I hate to say that. Um,
and, and there is a level of, to
get to be a black belt in Jujitsu.
Sure. You could say in general it
means you're a committed person.
In general. It means you're a
hardworking person in general.
It means that you've been humbled by
your experiences on the map in general.
But it is no way a fact.
And there are people in the Jujitsu
game that are swindlers and fiefs and
they're untrustworthy.
And there's a black belt in Jujitsu that
can be bullies and there's people in
Jiu Jitsu that can be predators
and you know, Jujitsu,
it's a power.
And sometimes people that are power hungry
recognize that power and they pursue
the gaining of Jujitsu power
and then they abuse that power.
So like any,
um,
abusive situation where one person has
a perceived power over another person,
it can get very ugly.
And there's all kinds of abuses that
I've seen take place over the years and a
Jujitsu world, financial
abuses, physical abuse,
and even sexual abuse.
So I just wanted to get that out there.
That being a Jujitsu black belt,
Brown belt, purple belt, blue belt,
white belt doesn't make
someone a good person.
So you need to be careful if you do two
doesn't make you a god and it certainly
doesn't make you a saint,
but it does give you power and everybody
has to recognize that there's people
out there that are,
their goal is to abuse power.
And I think the same thing goes
with any glorified position in life,
you know, and I actually see that
sometimes with, you know, uh, uh,
standing in a company,
a being a veteran,
like being a veteran doesn't mean that
you're a saint by any stretch of the
imagination being a seal.
Right?
I know a lot of seals and
there's plenty of seals.
They got out of the seal teams and
they're upstanding awesome citizens.
Mothers also scoundrels and Ms. Green
since swindlers like I said,
and they're using the seal name that they
have to promote themselves and to take
advantage of other people.
So,
okay,
keep your guard up,
keep your guard up and make sure you judge
people not based on what Jujitsu belt
they have.
Hmm.
Or what veteran status it
is that they brag about,
but who they are as a person.
Okay.
And I just wanted to get that out there
because we sit here and talk about
Jujitsu and there's so many great
people in Jujitsu, man. It's wonderful.
You roll into some series,
you see somebody with cauliflower ears
and you start talking to me. It's great.
And you, you, you know, there's
just a bunch of great people.
I mean we were on the map
today for two hours, you know,
and we train for an hour and 15 minutes
and they were just hanging out just
talking because that's what we do and
we're talking about everything and it's,
so there's great people in Jujitsu.
It's a great family,
a situation.
But you do have to be careful.
It is not a blanket.
Um,
okay.
Blanket statement that because someone's
a Jujitsu black belt for instance,
that they are a trustworthy person cause
there's some scumbags out there. Yeah,
I'm, and then that's that
can, and the fact that,
and I talked to Brady about this every
once in a while where you go in Jujitsu
and it seems like everyone just identifies
with each other and later on you find
out, oh shoot, that guy's like a
lawyer and that guy is a doctor.
Or that guy's like a different and that
guys or whatever and this person's from
this area and we all just get along
on the, Yep. Everyone gets along.
And the black belt,
he has so much like he tell him,
well like for the most part
it's PR. It's pretty, you know,
everyone's really good at
Jujitsu for the most part. Right.
And that's why you can kind of,
especially if you're kind of new or
maybe like their first year or something
like that, where you're going around
and Dang, my whole year of Jujitsu,
it's been great. People come
on, the man in the, oh my gosh,
she's all my new friends.
That's a big one meant all my new friends
is so cool and I got this whole thing.
It's like your whole life is better.
And then,
so your guard is down in the in call,
almost like a conditioning way.
You're just like, hey, if
you're in, did you get two?
You must be dope in every way.
And then you get these like outliers that
they're in the game, you know, and they,
and they take advantage like there where
they can, you know, and some do, but yeah,
you gotta, you gotta always
kind of watch over that. Yep.
So just if your spider senses are
going up or first of all, turn them on,
turn them on, turn them
off. And then if they go up,
start to maybe ask more
questions than you are.
And don't get yourself in a situation
where you know you're going to regret
what's going on because you believed that
someone was a good person because they
had some status that you consider
to be an honorable status. Yup.
Hate to say it, man. I hate to, I
hate to have to kind of bring that,
bring all that, all that Jiu Jitsu
down in this, you know, there's,
and then I'll tell you something else.
There's aspects of
Jujitsu where people lose
their minds, right? They
get crazy. And some of it,
you know,
with that whole school thing
we just talked about where
people start going crazy
about who owns students, right? No.
Like No.
Like I'm on own in any students.
I'm happy to have people that train at
my gym and I'm happy to work with them
and train them. Well, I don't
know, hone anybody. Right.
And there's people that get that crazy.
There's people that get crazy parents
that goes cycle on their kids and go level
seven.
You know,
I'm living vicariously through their
kids and push their kids until the kids
hate Jujitsu.
And I'll tell you,
I push my kids too hard when they were
younger for sure. That's looking back.
You know, everyone's, oh, the big
parenting advice from Jocko, man,
I push my kids too hard.
It made them compete too much,
mate who compete in harder brackets.
Older kids have your kids all the
time and it made you did so. Not Fun.
But I didn't break them
mentally from that.
So you gotta be careful that you
gotta be careful of the whole. Um,
you gotta be careful of Jujitsu is a
power and it's really easy to get suckered
into the point where you feel like you
should exercise your power over other
people, um, on the mats or
otherwise. You know, if you,
if you ever go into the gym
and it's making you feel
really good to tap everyone
out, like you're feeling better than
them, just start to check yourself, man.
Because that's not,
that's not helping you because there's
someone out there that's can tap you.
There's someone else. And if you're
taking those abusives out on other people,
so again, to beginners in Jujitsu,
it's, you're going to get tapped out.
You're going to get tapped out a lot,
but there shouldn't be anyone that
is smashing you and abusing you.
That's a much higher belt than you write.
Another white belt might
not even get that yet.
They're just happy they're submitting you.
Right?
But when anyone that's been around
a little bit more, they should be,
you should feel like, hey, that guy just,
he didn't abuse me. Yeah.
She didn't abuse me.
She just beat me and I know
what happened and it's cool.
Hmm. Yeah. In, in even that,
that's kind of weird and interesting too
where abuse can come in weird different
forms to, you know, like if cause
there's a difference. Okay. So,
so like Jeff Glover for example,
if you,
if Jeff Bavor is cause he has fun when
he rolls, that's a big part of his game.
And um, let's say, Oh, I'm a
new white belt, maybe, you know,
and I come my role against
Jeff Glover and heat and it's,
let's say it's I a six minute round and
just in training in Jeff taps him out 25
times. That's not, that's not
abuse. You know, you're just,
you're just doing some missions whole on
you. He's doing his thing or whatever.
If someone's like grinding
you and in doing, you know,
abusing you or trying to make you look
stupid or something like that because
like, oh yeah, I know dude, you
see you don't kind of thing.
Or maybe there's some girls
that he's trying to pro,
then that starts to get into music.
But I
don't ever watch me and dean role because
when one of us is having a good day
and the other one's having a bad day,
it's straight up abusive.
But that's you and dean.
And you'll notice that if when you
established like solid training partners,
then that becomes part of the game.
I'm going to try to abuse you.
And so that's different.
That's what I mean by like dynamic as
far as like we're recognizing what abuse
is because if you get tapped out 25
times in the, it seems like, Dang,
you didn't have to like go black belt on
him. He's a light bulb. Well, well, yeah,
he went black belt on him, but he wasn't
abusing them. You know what I mean?
That's like that. That's a well within
the confines of the game. For sure.
For sure.
There's a big difference between that.
I know this to translate this for
people that don't do Jujitsu yet. Uh,
think about also this with
any status structure, right?
In the work, in the military, in,
in the hierarchy of any
company or industry where
if you're feeling good about
bossing people around, you're
doing something wrong, man,
you're doing something wrong.
If your goal
of what you're doing is based on you,
if you're saying,
look,
I'm going to be the best and I'm gonna be,
this is what's important to me. Yeah. If
that's what you're saying is a leader,
put yourself in check because that's just
pure ego coming out when you're saying,
look,
I want to be the best in this.
And I think there's a weird thing that
happens with people that are go getters
and they hear someone that's a go getter
that we'll hear some person that's been
successful in business and that person
that's been successful in business will
be like,
you know what?
I said I was going to be the
best and here I am on the best.
And you've got to set your goals,
you've got to put 'em out there and you
got to let everyone know that you're
going to run them over if you're getting
your way. And that sounds really cool.
And,
and I guarantee if you went back and
you follow that person through their
career, they were completely
not like that. They were,
they were politically sensitive.
They understood other people's needs.
They didn't go, Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm going to take over this business. No,
they didn't do that. They said, hey,
nice to meet you. How are you doing?
What are you,
what are we trying to make happen here?
They made it a goal for the team. Even
if the deep underlying goal is, uh,
is a selfish one,
let's say the outer
goal should not be that.
It should not be, hey,
I'm going to be the best.
I'm going to be the ruler of this
company. I'm going to be, no,
we don't want to hear that. Like when
you, you, you know, I just take all,
I want to be the president of the United
States who wants that person to be
present,
the United States and I sure don't,
I don't want that person to be president.
I would say it's if someone says,
I'm going to be the CEO of this company
now, what do you think of that? You think,
okay, so this person's ego is really,
really big and do you think yourself,
you know what, that I don't like that.
You need to put that. So if that's your
attitude and you think
you're being fired up,
keep that goal internal.
Don't be announcing that gold blue side.
State your goals and let the
world know you're here. No,
because you sound like an egomaniac.
What you should say is like,
you know what I want to
do with this company?
I want to help this company
grow the best I can.
And you know what's important to be
about being in a leadership position?
What's important to me about being in a
leadership position is making sure that
the people underneath me, they get
better and they reach their goals.
This isn't about me.
This is about the people that are on my
team and I want to make them successful.
Now, who wants to work for that person?
I do sign me up. But when I say,
Hey boss, nighttime, nice to meet
you, what's your, you know what,
what's your goal here at the company?
My goal is to be CEO, to be the boss.
So you're going to step on my
back to get their sounds like fun.
Don't sign me up for that guy.
I don't want to work with that person.
I want to work with somebody that's about
the team and I don't want to work with
somebody that's gonna be abusive,
just like I don't want to train it.
Anybody's Jujitsu Academy that's going
to have that abusive mentality and
they're out there. So I wanted to tie
that back into the business world.
The instructor, I'm the
instructor. Your instructor,
you don't go into Napoleon dynamite,
you know bout your sensei.
They make fun of that. And
it's funny and, and there's,
I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with that.
There's a lot of tradition
in Jujitsu as well. You know,
you bow to your instructor, you now
when you come on and off the mat. Yeah,
I'm not super into that stuff. You know
what I mean? I'm laid back. I know I'm,
I'm pretty laid back when it comes
to the Jujitsu traditions. Yeah.
Most of the bowing to the instructor
in Jujitsu is more like bar.
It's like bow to Jujitsu almost like
and not foul like bow down. It's more D,
it's like show respect. Like if you
go to even more traditional schools,
even when Rhonda was teaching
at our school, you know,
you buy it to all of the
instructors because they're
the ones providing that you
do. And then you bought it Helio Gracie
cause he's the one who kind of provide,
you know, so it was more
about that. You did too. Yeah.
It doesn't have that feel and you've
got to make sure that you're not getting
that crossover where it goes from,
hey bow to Jujitsu and flavor.
Pay respect to a beautiful
thing to bow to me. Yes.
And it's the same thing in the
business world. If you're saying, look,
there's nothing wrong with treating your
CEO with respect and your CEO should be
treated with respect or your boss,
you treat your bothers with respect.
Absolutely. Like, Hey boss,
what do you need me to do?
Hey, hey sir, in the military,
you know, you call those senior officers,
sir. There there's, there's nothing,
you know, shouldn't feel
degraded by doing that. But
if for instance, in the military,
if it's like, hey, you call me sir,
you know, okay, I see what I'm dealing
with here in the, in the business world,
if people are,
you know,
if you as an individual are thinking,
you better show me the respect I deserve.
You got issues,
I got issues. You got to earn that. If
someone's not giving you the SPEC, don't,
don't look at them and demand it.
Yeah.
Look at yourself and demand that you
become a better leader where they give you
the respect, not because you asked for
it, but because you deserved it. Yeah.
There's a big difference. That's
funny man. Give me the respect.
I deserve to have them either respect
most of the time, most not all of them.
Most of them. Once someone says yes,
give me the respect, idea, deserve.
It's when they are being given the respect
they deserve, which is probably not.
Most of the time when people are saying,
give me the respect I deserve,
they don't deserve the
respect they're asking for me.
Yeah, they need to get their
head together. Awesome.
What are we got time for?
One more. That's one. Jocko,
I had had a few rough months,
some setbacks at work that
hurt me financially, which
is stressed out. My family,
I'm late on some payments.
I'm falling further behind at work.
I don't want to tap out,
but I just don't know where to start.
Well, you know what, that's,
that's just kind of the way that
life works.
Sometimes it's Murphy's law.
When things go wrong,
they always seem to happen at once and
they just compound on top of each other
and it's,
it's pretty easy sometimes to to feel
beaten when you're faced with all those
issues and all those problems and
they all hit you at the same time.
But
let me tell you that that
doesn't mean give up.
In fact,
it means the opposite.
It means it's time for you to fight harder
to dig in means it's time for you to
go on the warpath
and that starts with one of the
fundamental laws of combat leadership.
Prioritize and execute. What's
the biggest problem? Well,
what's causing the most
stress? Family. Okay.
Sit them down.
Explain where you are at.
Be Blunt,
be up front,
and then give them the simple plan of
how you're going to get things back on
track.
Don't sugarcoat it.
You give it to them straight.
Next you got some,
some late payments.
Call those creditors up.
Explain to them what's going on.
Set up some kind of a of a,
of a minimum payment plan so you can start
making some progress and get them off
your back.
And then you got your job
right, your phone at work.
Okay? Talk to your boss.
Face it. Tell him that you're
going to step up your game.
Tell him you're going to be at work early.
You're going to be at work late.
You're going to be at work during lunch.
You're going to be wherever you need to
be whenever he needs you to be there.
Tell him you're going to get after it and
tell him that you were 100% committed.
Yeah.
Tufts supporting him and
the company and the mission.
And then you get started.
And I'm going to tell you right now,
it won't be easy.
It will be hard because life is hard.
That's what life is.
And these challenges,
these challenges that you face,
they're going to do their
best to take you down.
Do not let them stand up.
Dig In.
Okay.
Line up those problems and confront them.
Face them,
fight them.
Do not let them bring you down.
In fact,
in fact,
let lose challenges.
Raise you up.
Let them elevate you.
Yeah.
Let their demands and their
trials make you stronger.
Let the adversity you face today,
okay.
Turn you into a better person tomorrow.
So,
so when the future,
you look back at these
struggles heg you say to them,
thank you.
You made me better.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So echo
let's cloves it on out.
How can everyone get on board with
the program here and, and sport?
The little podcast we got
going in enforcement, not
reinforcement. Reinforcement.
Yes.
So indeed few ways.
First on top of supporting this podcast
and you're going to want to support
yourself, I think supplementation.
Why don't we talk about this?
I know, I know. Um, anyway, on
it has the best supplements.
We all know this.
Krill oil dot.
My krill oil in echoes in
the game. Actually I'm, I'm
staying on it every month anyway.
So on it on a.com/jocko 10% off.
So supplement your wallet as well.
So the Krill oil, that's for
your joints warrior bars as well.
I think Donald's a good
one. Yes. Room Tech.
Shroom tech is kind of, okay. So
victor was talking about, he's like,
I'm on shroom tech today,
all fired up yet.
So tell me what you think about this.
So I used to take shroom tech all
the time and be like, and I felt,
and I felt like it kind of gave me an
advantage because you know how cardio
conditioning stuff is a tool in
Jujitsu or can be if you use it.
Do you think that's an advantage?
Do, I think cardio has an advantage.
[inaudible] tech is like all he took.
Shroom tech doesn't count because
I took shrooms deck and tapped out.
Someone who I don't tap up. There's,
there's two ways to look at that.
Well that's a word.
Shroom tech is really good.
Shroom tech did not make you tap out,
tapped out, but indirectly it could have,
you know what I mean?
So I guess,
I guess the answer to this would be since
you were able with shroom tech to do
more, it's pushing you harder so you're
stepping up your game overall. Yeah,
I'm allowed to train better because you
can train harder because of your shroom
tech. Yeah. So it is,
as far as I'm concerned,
permissible to do that because you're
just trying to get yourself better and
[inaudible] helps you do that. Now you
might have to, you know, give a caveat,
put us little asterisks next to
your tap house on the shroom tech.
So quite there. That's like a wind
ATM today. When we got done training,
I was like, you know, I didn't take any
shroom tech today. So maybe you know,
and you were like, I either
did I, so I said okay.
It was a level playing field
in Stephen. Yeah, the, the um,
it's like when you run the hundred
meter dash in the wind, the sun,
there's a strong wind like you'll,
you'll get the record,
but there's a star there asked her,
he says wind dated record. Oh really?
This is wind aided? Yes. Still your
record. But it's the wind ate. It sort of,
I know is that they try and
do you like Yo when you're,
when you get your shroom tech and you set
your PR in, you know, in like, you know,
a wad or something like this. You
got to put the star. There's no PR,
but I was on a shoot. Yeah. Maybe. Maybe
you don't have to do valid and do that.
Maybe, I don't know. But you might anyway.
Nonetheless, shroom tech sport though.
There's two,
this shroom tech.
It's the shroom tech something
else. I'm talking about this. Yes.
Yeah. Luckily I haven't had to
take the immune. Yeah. But no,
that's for general immunity. Right.
That's so close to the thing. But anyway,
that one, probably not a peak
performance enhancing supplement.
Maybe it is indirectly anyway on
it. Uh, it's there from audit.
You get 10% off on a.com/jocko take the
Alpha brain to think a little better.
Like it makes you think it's proven.
By the way that St lie,
it's legitimately proved.
Not like the 19%.
The 90% is pretty legitimately
through as far as I know. Cole Miller,
Colt meal there, UFC fighter Mike
Best. I mean I got an email today,
got his rash guard, uh, just
started Jujitsu like, you know,
a lot of us have been and so emails me
and says I was going to bring the email
and read it. It's short. So he's
like, um, he's like, hey man,
I tapped out my Jujitsu attorneys.
Quite awesome.
I tapped out my first blue
belt today. Dang. And he said,
guess what I was wearing?
He said,
I'm not going to attribute it to the
rash guard specifically, but let's,
let's face it. It was the rash
guard. Okay. So that being said,
there's some super rash guards on Jocko
store.com I redid the website by the
way. Not much in effect. It's
just kind of redone nonetheless.
This rash guards on there, they're
cool. They improve your performance.
19% tech I guess.
I mean apparently 19 to 35% really?
That's the range evidently. Anyway. Cool.
Rash guards. You can check those out.
[inaudible] dot com there's
some shirts there too.
Was that you telling me that
you saw someone with a shirt
on? None. No, no victor.
Victor was saying,
oh paid above the so
that's the thing when we,
and I said this before of course.
So you know if you listen,
you know that I try to put more than
just the one layer on the shirt.
It's kind of,
there's a bunch of insights stuff.
Actually if you talking about
the layers on the shirts,
it started to become a thing I'm
telling. No, I'm saying cause it,
you know why it's starting to become
thing cause it cause it is a thing.
So you're going to have to
like on some future shirt,
you'd have to actually put
the word layers. Layers. Yeah.
It might be don't either way.
He was saying how he recognized the shirt
and when you see someone else wearing
like, you know, they, you know,
so it's not like you see a quick
silver shirt and it's like, Hey,
I'm wearing critters. You know what I
mean? It's different. It's way different.
This stuff, you know, if you
listen, you know, you're like,
ah, anyway, check them out.
If you like,
go grab one and you can support that
way and force and then Amazon click
through. What that it does is
anytime you shop on Amazon,
just clicked through on our website,
Jocko, podcast.com or the store.
There's a little section there.
Uh,
people can do a lot of Christmas
and holiday shopping. Yeah.
So if you really want to get your
support on the game full speed,
it doesn't cost anybody
anything, doesn't, it's,
it's just supports the podcast while
you're doing your normal stuff.
So that's awesome. That is
appreciated. Yeah, man, it gets,
I mean the key there really is to remember
to click through before you go shop.
That's it. Anyway. It's a good way
to support them as on, so yeah,
on the website again, you just click on
the Amazon link before you do shopping,
then boom, support, actively,
efficiently, solid. Um,
and then of course subscribe
on the, uh, on Itunes, on
the iTunes or stitcher.
And there's some other like
Google play, Google play. Oh yeah,
that's a good one too. Those little
podcasts, layups, but yet be a subscriber.
Men in the game,
straight up.
Write a review on the, maybe this
is, I don't know what this is.
It's just one of those things. We're
at like 900 something reviews. Oh yeah.
So of course
I'm going to go home and write a hundred
reviews tonight myself and get to a
thousand,
a thousand,
a thousand reviews even mean.
I know what's good about it is it is.
If you wrote a review,
I read it.
I've read all the reviews that are on
there and it's cool because it's good
feedback and it lets us know that people
are listening and that they're in the
game. Yeah. Which is cool.
That is plenty of them.
And I want to get to a thousand
for no good. Of course,
when he does that ego you
think or maybe OCD or both?
Cause you know how like
you're like, hey, I don't,
you know how like when you pump the
gas, you know, and you're like, oh,
I'm going to, I'm gonna get, if
you're not filling up, you're like,
I'm going to get it right on
the $20 market. It's like,
it's a weird thing. Anyway,
something like that. Um, you know how like
people, they'll celebrate, hey, I got to,
you know, a thousand subscribers
or whatever. You know, people,
they'll celebrate in the upload,
sit and be like, well, like,
why didn't you celebrate at like
1,001 or nine, eight, nine. See,
when I get to a thousand I won't
celebrate anything. I'll be like,
I need to get to 2000 and it's not even
anything I can stop from my own brain
thinking. He just thinks that
way. So yeah. So your thing
is like different. Yeah,
just like it's a,
it's almost like a score and I go,
oh well what's my score right now?
Right now it's 920 to three yeah.
I want my score to be a thousand.
Why? I have no good reason. And you
yet nonetheless subscribe.
That's how you can support
and youtube subscribe to that.
You know if you're down, if you're
in to youtube and watching videos,
I'm subscribed to that.
I think I'm going to put out
another one here pretty soon. Yeah,
we hear that Queen Bee are going to
put on another one. We hear that a lot,
you know? Hey, it kind of like the email
lists. You know how like, oh, okay,
I'll talk about in a second.
But you don't like the email list?
We have you sign up the insider's list
and just sign up and be like, Hey,
I'll send you, you know some,
we'll send you some stuff.
I'm not going to send you stuff every day.
I'm just kind of like the youtube, Hey,
I'm going to put more videos.
Maybe not every week,
but you know there will be more,
more than basically any.
Meanwhile on my end,
people are like, Hey Jocko, keep making
a podcast every week. I say your end,
they tell you, hey echo, can you make
some more videos? And you're like,
you know what? They
can, they can wait low.
That's the artist in you.
No, no, no. That's nice. The
artists right there. I'll,
yeah,
we'll do some more videos.
I would hope that we're all
sitting here holding our breath.
Their Echo Charles for you
to make more than, yeah,
I see what you're doing. He gives
you like stroking my ego. Like,
oh we're waiting for your next video,
but I'm like,
you guys are waiting from wavy. I'm
going to put on the video, be like, yes,
I want to my video guys,
have you ever made, have you ever made
a video that you got done and you said,
I'm not even going to release
this thing cause it's too bad.
Yes, I have a whole series. Yeah.
Echo telling you bro. It's, yeah,
there's like one of them's called, um,
for people that you find on
Facebook and like cone ends in it.
It's like the people who take p one of
them is like two people who take pictures
of themself, but they want to act like
they're taking a picture of something,
you know?
But it's like,
it's like this thing and it just didn't
come out good anyway. Nonetheless. Yeah.
I am very weary of these things
anyway, so yeah. Support that way. Oh,
back to the store. Jocko store.
Oh, there's some new stuff.
Is it annoying to sit here and talk
about like this stuff right here? Um,
no, I don't think so. I mean, if,
if I didn't have Debbie and everyone's
saying, well, where's the girl stuff?
You know, and they're just like,
all right. You know, like not
maybe just so I think about it
like, I always think like, okay,
we can probably cut this, you know,
hey, let's just run through, you know,
how to support the podcast. Did you
take three minutes? For some reason?
It turns into a 15 minute conversation
and I don't, I don't, it's,
I never intend to do that.
And then when I listened to it,
I actually laugh at most of it
and I think it's pretty funny.
So I don't even know.
We should do like a two hour podcast.
I'll us just talking about how to support
the podcast because it might be pretty
funny cause you're laughing right now.
I was laughing a second ago and maybe
that'd be the greatest topic ever.
Okay. So in that regard, I,
I'm not saying this is proof,
but this evidence and this happened
more than once by the way. So
you know that we'll
order a shirt and yeah,
it's online so you can't try on the
shirts. So people will be like, Hey,
well you know, what's the shirt sizes
or whatever. And they'll say, hey,
I need a bigger size,
or I don't know,
I def forgot to change my address
or something where, you know, they,
they require it another shirt. Yeah.
So there'd be times I'd be like, oh,
I'll just send it to you. Like you
got lost in the mail, whatever.
I'll just send it so it just
send it and they're like,
no, no I do. Oh No, no. Here,
this is what it was two. And that
happened before. But here's, there's,
here's a very specific
one I'm thinking about.
It's where I sent apparently two shirts.
They got two shirts they were supposed
to get. One was supposed to get Wonka.
Yeah. And they were
like, I got two shirts,
I'm keeping him tell me where
to pay. Tell me like, tell him,
tell me how I can pay, cause he
can't go and click another, you know,
it'll go in the order says that. And he
was told where I can pay. I was like, no,
I keep the shirt. That's all
you, you know, give it to
somebody. And they're like,
I demand to pay. It's like part of the
reason is to support this, the podcast,
you know, so, and I'm Kinda like, Dang,
there are enforcements out there
who embrace the reinforcing.
That's why.
That's why I think this is relevant.
Well, yeah. Well, I guess my is, is
that when you were
talking about this stuff,
what should be a 32nd thing?
Turns into a 15 minute thing.
Light gets happening right now and when
I listened to the podcast and I'll start
going, oh, here come the advertisements.
I got to make a note to say shorten these
down. And then I say, Oh you know what?
That was actually funny as
hell. So I dunno, maybe I'm,
maybe I'm just ultra sensitive. Yeah.
Maybe just like the ritual thing. Mm.
Maybe dug in. So what were you saying?
The store? Yeah, the store. Hey there's,
there's some new stuff is the
first time I'm saying it publicly,
but there's hoodies in there.
They're pretty cool.
Apparently Jocko says,
oh good. I like them.
I'm also like, I'd did the
patches. Where there, there Ft.
You know how j p last week
said federal dark earth.
Apparently it's flat.
Darker.
Not to be confused with flat
earth cause people won't.
People think the earth is flat or we
don't want Eddie Bravo to get fired up
about being a flat cause he thinks that
his conspiracy things that he believes
in. I don't think so. Nobody's in
all kinds of crazy conspiracies.
Yeah Man, I'm not gonna argue.
I'm not going to argue the
rubber guard about with him. I don't
want to talk about nothing else man.
That's too, he's got too many facts
and figures about stuff. You know,
facts and figures about all
kinds of conspiracy stuff
that I don't want to argue
with. It's all I'm good with
him being in that world.
I don't want to enter that world. I'm
saying how that world and you know why,
cause I guess I'm too blind to see. The
reality is, okay, I'm going to stay blind.
You all good. But the salt
flat, dark earth, there's a is,
it's the official one where if you know,
is it two by three? Two by three. Okay.
So let's come up as far
as the new stuff on Jocko,
store.com [inaudible] to come
and look at the stuff on there.
If you like it,
go grab one and you can enforce,
reinforce and support this podcast that
way, which is awesome. I appreciate it.
You can also get some,
some Jocko white tea,
which I've been drinking liberally all
night long and I'm feeling pretty good
right now. How do you have
some cause we're out. Yeah,
well so I've got massive quantities.
I actually told our supplier I will never,
we will never run out of this again.
How do we make that happen?
And then they told me how to make it
happen so it's going to be back in Amazon
directly and we will never run
out of it again. That's my hope.
I ordered a lot of it.
I learned a lot of it cause I didn't know
that people are going to be so went to
it. And then I realized, cause you
know sometimes you're in a bubble. Yes.
And you think something's really
cool and no one else does.
I have been in that bubble many times
in my life where I thought something was
really cool and then I get outside the
bubble and people don't think it's cool
my whole life.
So I was under suspicion
that this situation where I like this tea,
this random tea,
and then I got it tweaked to my specific
liking and I thought, well, okay,
not only have I taken a random thing and
then I've tweaked it to be specifically
what I like. I'm thinking to myself
like, what seven people in the world,
we're going to dig this.
Well,
what I should have done was taken it and
given it to a bunch of people and said,
hey, is this, what do you think of this?
Because by the time we did that we,
we basically did that and you realize
that it tastes really, really good.
It's a unique,
flavorful taste and I think that's like
part one is that it tastes really good.
It doesn't taste like anything else.
It's just got a very,
it doesn't taste like a juice.
It doesn't taste like a tea.
What does it tastes like?
It just tastes like it tastes like
what it tastes like and it tastes good.
And universally, universally people go, oh
yeah, that's, that's, that tastes great.
It's just a universally
good tasting thing.
And then on top of that, you get the
micro dose of caffeine, just a microdose.
So it's this thing that just comes in
subsurface and just gives it to you,
but it doesn't override your normal
senses. And then on top of that,
you've got the antioxidant thing,
which for all I know,
it's just just repairing and
taking care of your body, right?
So you combine all those things together
and we've got something very popular on
our hands. And again, I
thought that inside my bubble,
I thought it was something inside
my bubble was going to be popular.
But now I realize that it's a very,
everybody loves the way it tastes and
everybody loves the way it makes you feel.
So what I gotta do is order, you
know, through the manufacturer,
ordered a ton of it and go online.
And you know, some people
also said, hey, you know what,
Jocko stuff cost too much.
And it costs a lot because we got a high
quality container to put it in the tin
as it's known luxury, the
luxury, the luxury is the luxe.
I didn't say luxurious, I didn't,
I forgot to rewind that part,
but the tin costs a lot of money
to make and so that's what it is.
Well when people said it was too
expensive, I said, okay, cool.
I'll put a in box also.
So we got to come in at a box.
You can still get it in the team because
you need at least one tin, right?
Tactical multipurpose tactics when you
probably need a few of them in your house.
Pens, check screws and nails. Check. Um,
you auntie itself,
check.
And then you're also going to be able to
buy it in big box with a hundred count
in there. So we're taking care of you
on that end. Yeah. Again, here I was,
all I was wrote down to say was
we have Jocko white tea unset.
I talk about it for eight minutes.
What is wrong with me? You gotta well,
and you know what? I think it's too much
Jocko. White tea has gotten me talking,
got me mentally engaged at such a
level that I need to just take it easy.
Then it's that feedback loop. Also
we've got a book, extreme ownership.
It's about combat leadership.
Therefore it's about all
leadership written by myself
and my brother Leif Babin
and if you buy the audio version it
gets read by myself and my brother Leif
Babin so you can check that out
is also an Amazon. Appreciate it.
Following that,
if you happen to want to continue this
little conversation that we're having
right now or you just want to get
after it on the interwebs, that's cool.
You can do it. We are
there. We're on Twitter,
we're on Instagram and you know
that we've had that face bookie
echo.
Echo is at Echo,
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink
and thanks to everybody for listening,
for joining us as we join you trying to
figure out how to get better and to my
brothers in arms,
in the military overseas,
hunting down evil and destroying it.
You all out there stay aggressive and
stay ahead of the enemy and the police and
law enforcement.
Thanks for holding the line
and fighting crime and the firefighters.
Of course.
Thanks for your vigilance and
your courage under actual fire
and the rest of you troopers
out there listening,
honing your skills,
building buildings,
creating creations,
designing designs,
developing developments,
working on what you are working on.
Thanks for your relentless pursuit of
excellence and of growth and of progress.
And most of all,
thank you
for getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.
Okay.